- I guess because you're
used to the normal dynamics
in anime where they're like,
"Oh a hot girl turns up
and he wants to have sex with her.
But then he actually just starts her.
- Yeah, he just starts fucking her,
I'm like, "Who is this chad?"
I've never seen such a big
chad in animated before.
What the fuck?
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to trash taste.
I'm your host Connor.
And I'm tired of smiling.
(all laugh)
- Great intro.
- We all just had a very strong coffee,
but I'm again with Joey.
- Hi.
- And Garnt.
- Hello.
- No nicknames today.
I just didn't think to do that.
- We're keeping it simple today, are we?
- I mean, that's who we are, right?
- I'm very tired.
(all laugh)
Every, every day before we do an episode,
I wake up at 7:00 AM to
go to a Japanese class
for two hours.
- How's that going for you?
- It's going.
- It's going forward.
- Sometimes you're too
tired to learn things.
And I remember being this in university.
I would be asleep basically.
- But then they make you talk.
So I kind of-
- Yeah, how's it going for you?
Cause me and Connor have
gone very different routes
in terms of how we've
approached learning Japanese.
Cause you've taken
classes and I'm completely
self-taught because I
realized in university
how classes really slowed me down
in terms of my learning process.
Just the biggest problem I've encountered
is self discipline.
- That's exactly why I wanted lessons.
(Garnt laughs)
Cause, the way I see it, right.
Lessons are okay, if I'm
keeping up with these lessons,
these are the bare minimum that someone
at any mental capacity can learn Japanese.
- [All] Right.
- So if I'm learning it
at this structured course
that anyone can do, right.
I should learn X amount of Japanese.
- Yeah, because we know that
everyone who's homeschooled,
doesn't actually do anything.
- Also I'm a liar, dude.
I lie to myself a lot.
when I say I'm gonna learn Japanese
I will do everything in my power
to think that I'm learning
Japanese, but not do it.
- During the quarantine,
because at this point
in the episode, it's pretty much done.
(indistinct chatter)
- It's pretty much open.
But during the quarantine,
because you know,
Connor you didn't go to
Japanese lessons right?
- Yeah.
- You had to do zoom lessons.
- I hated Zoom lessons.
- And you were telling
me that most of the time
you were just playing Arknights.
(all laughing)
You were just like, "Yes,
I am listening teacher."
- It's like, new unit.
- Problem was right, is that I was in a...
My class is mainly like housewives
and people who are much older than me.
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
- So, a lot of them weren't tech-savvy.
So, they were all spending
10 minutes saying,
"Hello, hello, can you hear me?
Hello."
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
Meanwhile, I'm already set up.
I've got my whole
YouTube is set up, right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I've got two monitors,
three mobile phones.
You know what I mean?
- You got the green screen in the back.
- Yeah, yeah.
(all laughing)
- The pro stream is set up.
(indistinct chatter)
- It's just like when I'm at my PC,
I'm doing everything but what
I'm supposed to be doing.
- Right.
- So, I got two monitors, right.
So, I can also put my webcam
wherever the fuck I want,
so when they're like, "Are you looking?"
And like, "Yeah."
I'm doing work on the other
monitor [indistinct] else.
And I know you're like,
"Well, Connor you're
paying for those lessons.
Why would you not do it?"
I don't know.
I paid to be in class, you know.
- Yeah, exactly.
That's that's university
in a nutshell though.
I mean, you're, you're paying to be here.
You're paying to learn.
"Oh, why do I have to
get a classes though?"
- I don't have to.
I can just study from home.
(Garnt laughs)
- I hate going to the class and having
to do that and be back
in that environment.
Because you know, I
wanted to get out of that.
But at the same time I am learning stuff.
It is slow.
And I do a lot of study on
my own time, mainly Kanji.
Because they don't teach
us Kanji in my class.
- They don't teach you Kanji?
- It's practical Japanese.
So it's all supposed to be for speaking
and getting by.
Because to reiterate, when I say classes,
I think most people will assume every day.
I do classes two times a week
for two hours, that's it?
So not a lot of time to
learn a language really.
- Right.
That's better than nothing I guess.
It's much better than doing nothing.
Right.
- Exactly.
Because for me, I've tried to focus
less on the reading and just
pure conversational for me.
And actually one thing
that's really helped
with that is not watching
anime actually, but-
- What?
- But watching virtual YouTubers.
So I've I've really gotten
into watching virtual YouTubers
- Really?
- For the last few months.
Yeah.
- Who are you into?
- Asa Coco is probably my
favorite one at the time
of right now.
She just had her 3D debut.
I'm sounding like a
total fucking degenerate.
- Is that the one you
simped over in [indistinct].
- Yeah, I saw that.
- All over Twitter was, Garnt was simping.
- I was very drunk at the time
and I saw she was having
her first 3D debut.
And I'm, "I'll just fucking throw her
like 30 bucks, whatever."
And then as soon as I did
my Twitter notification fucking exploded.
- Gigguk is simping over VTuber.
- Imagine getting caught simping,
but over virtual YouTube.
- Well, because it's actually
really helped my Japanese
way more than watching anime.
Because with watching anime,
I dunno what the anime watching experience
has been for you Connor since
you've started learning.
But for me I found it a lot more difficult
to watch anime now that
I'm learning Japanese
because you know when
you read the subtitles,
and then you kind of
understand what's going on.
So you wanna try to listen in
to what's what's being said.
But because you do that,
you kind of just miss
what's on the subtitles.
That's been my anime watching
experience recently and well-
- I imagine Joey is just
on his throne here being,
"Yes, tell me more about your struggles."
- What are these Subtitles you speak of?
- Okay, one thing that
I noticed that bugs me,
is that now that I know,
I'd say a very basic amount.
Right?
Very minimal.
Not, enough to watch
an episode and be like,
"Yup, I understood, all that."
But enough to get some sentences, right.
Is that when I read the subtitles
and obviously because in Japanese,
sometimes the subject at the
end of the sentence in English,
it's normally at the start in Japanese.
So sometimes you'll see a subtitle,
that comes with the other
half of the sentence.
So you're hearing the
sentence that's gonna come up.
- Yeah.
- And it's like, you're Johnson Joestar.
I was just like-
- [Connor And Garnt] I
know what you're gonna say.
- You're next line is gonna be.
(all laughing)
- And it kinda messes with you.
And then also like
(Connor laughing)
Just watching any hentai,
it's really frustrating.
Because I realized two minutes in,
I'm starting to be,
"Okay, what are they
saying, just a minute."
(speaking in Japanese)
- Means feels good.
Okay.
- Yeah, understand.
(speaking in Japanese)
- I guess though it makes
sense to watch VTubers though,
to learn Japanese.
Because you know, these are real people.
- No, exactly.
- Who are speaking.
They just look anime, but their mannerisms
and their phrasing,
even though they might be
playing a character, right?
- Yeah.
- It's still a real person.
- Because it feels like,
they're having an actual conversation.
Because you know watching an anime,
and you hear a conversation.
You're like, "I've never actually...
- This isn't a real conversation.
- This isn't a real conversation
that's happening right now.
And I'm zoning most of it out.
Whereas when I'm watching a YouTuber,
it feels like a genuine...
Like a Japanese conversation.
Like you're actually hearing a story
the way any person you talk
to Japan would talk like.
It's been way more useful
for me in learning Japanese
than it has been watching anime.
- Also because I guess with VTubers again,
they're real people, right?
So the speed that they talk
at as well is very real.
And it's not overly accentuated.
So it actually makes more sense
to get used to that kind
of speech, speed, than like
(speaking in Japanese)
No one talks like that, right?
- No, cause you're not it's
the anime voice acting voice,
you know what I mean?
Which is not how real people talk like.
This is true in I'd say dub as well.
You know you hear a dub voice actor,
or a dub performance.
And you're like, "This
isn't how real people talk.
This isn't how people talk."
- No, of course.
- It's very anime.
- Yeah.
- So it's more watching a live streamer.
So it's been...
I'm not gonna say that's...
I'm gonna say that's the only reason
I'm getting into VTubers.
But if you're trying to learn Japanese
I'd say VTubing is much
more useful than learning-
- It's educational, I swear.
(indistinct chatter)
- Than watching anime.
Because watching anime now for
me has become a lot harder.
And you get the joy of finding
that one VTuber you can simp.
(all laughing)
- You're like, "Oh yeah, that's my one."
- It's a little bit annoying
to watch anime sometimes.
But then also now
sometimes I can look away
just for a second
and I can still understand
what they said roughly.
Cause I'll know, three of
the five words that they say
and that after that I can
kind of piece together.
What was being said.
- Isn't that such a
gratifying moment though.
- It really is, I was
going to say as well,
one thing that I found really helpful
than I thought I would
dread is learning Kanji.
I think Lennon Kanji is so interesting.
I know you love your Kanji.
- Yeah.
- But learning has been so fun.
Just because when it slowly
starts to make sense,
it feels like an RPG,
where you're unlocking
the world where you live.
- Right?
- Yeah.
Because I can slowly start to read stuff
and then there's multiple different ways
to read a Kanji.
And then when you know both,
it's like, "Yeah, I'm kinda-
- You're like that one Isekai protai
who just comes in is
like, "What does this say?
I don't know."
And they're 12 episodes it, his like,
"Yeah, I get it."
(all laugh)
- Yeah, it's been really
helpful for just learning.
Speaking in general.
Because a lot of the words
have the same pronunciation,
and then obviously Kanji is
the way to differentiate it.
- Yeah, Kanji holds the meaning, right?
- Yeah.
- And sometimes reading a
whole sentence in Hiragana
is like a fucking nightmare.
- It is a nightmare.
And weirdly enough for
people who'd have no idea
about Japanese it might
be hot to think about,
but a full on Hiragana
or Katakana sentence
is so difficult to read sometimes.
Whereas Kanji is just like,
"Oh yeah, I know exactly what that means.
I know exactly how to read it."
- The way I see it, is that in English,
is that how we don't
need to read the word,
we know the shape of the word.
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- We can see a word.
I know the shape of the
word, I can read it.
And I think that's how
Kanji is to Japanese people.
Where they don't necessarily read it
but they recognize that the shape.
And then they just know what's
being said in the sentence
- Because have you seen that video
where you can read an entire paragraph?
Where if the word the
first letter is the same
the last letter is the
same and then you swap
all the letters in the middle,
you can still read what's going on.
Just because of how your fluency works.
- Yeah.
- I feel it would be the
same with Kanji as well.
- I think so, yeah.
It is the same.
But instead of the first and last letters
it's like does this have
one line in it or two?
It's that but just squinting really hard.
- Yeah, there are some
where there's so many lines
where I'm like, "How the fuck do people
just read it this fast?"
- I mean the more difficult
is when you start to write it.
Right?
- Yeah, true, true.
- That's when it starts to get difficult.
- Yeah, because I have an app
and it vibrates my phone if
you do the wrong stroke order.
(all laugh)
(Connor grunting)
- No.
- It's like, "That's not how you do it."
It's been good though,
because whenever write
a Kanji out in my class
in the right stroke order.
The teacher is like
(Connor grunting)
Like in the TV shows.
- Like, "Why?"
- What the fuck?
Because you never really think about
something like strike order.
You know what I mean?
Which stroke order is basically
the order you write it in.
- Yeah, because I write my
Ss the wrong way in English
and people freaking out.
- I've seen you write your S.
- Tell people how you write your Ss?
- You're supposed to do
it top to bottom right?
- Yeah, most people do it like that.
- Like that.
- I do it from top to bottom up.
And then swish down with the cursive.
I don't know why.
- How did you learn that?
- Dude, I was so bad at English in school.
So to clarify, right.
Okay, I'll just start the story with this.
We'll start strong, right.
I was so bad at English that
they put me with the kids
who you know we're not
good at anything, you know?
- Yeah.
I was in the English class for one year
with kids with learning disabilities.
- Right.
And I remember being dude, what the fuck?
(all laugh)
- Because okay.
I've always been really good
at most subjects in school
and, okay to clarify the reason
why my English was so bad
is because the only reading
and writing I ever did
was in Welsh.
Because my school was Welsh.
Everything I spoke in school,
and read was in Welsh.
But I obviously knew how to spell English.
Speak English obviously.
And then yeah, I remember we
did an English spelling test
and I got everything wrong.
But bear in mind I was like eight.
And I remember they said like
"Oh, can you smell the woods said for us?"
And I was like, "Yeah sure."
And I just-
- S-E-D.
- I put like Z-E-D.
And then my parents were like, "Oh no."
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Bear in mind, I never
read anything in English.
Reading at all.
It was just always video games.
So, yeah.
And I forgot why was I...
Why did this story come up?
I forgot why I was saying this now.
(indistinct chatter)
- Yeah, so I think I
learned how to write...
Because in English as well, in school
they teach you the stroke order.
- Do they?
I can't remember this.
- I learnt it when we had to...
I don't know if this is only in Australia
but I think I was in
fourth grade or something
- Yeah, because you have those
papers which are half width
and full width.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And you have to.
I learned how to do it when
we learned to write cursive.
- Yeah, because I
remember learning cursive,
and it kind of became a
thing where I for some reason
I just started writing
some of them weirdly,
and no one ever stopped me.
- I do what I want.
- And so I've always done.
I'll go into the A and then I'll go down
and then do the S up and then slash down.
- How do you write the number five.
Do you go from the bottom
or do you go from the top?
- It depends, I guess.
Whatever the situation.
- What do you mean it depends?
- Yeah, I don't know.
- How does that work?
- There's only one way to do it.
- Most of the time I
would do it from the top,
but I remember distinctively
I was doing it from the bottom for a while
and then I stopped that.
But I also used to write my fours like...
The correct way of doing...
How do you learn to
wright fours in Australia.
- I do it this way.
I do it that way.
- That's the way I learned.
But then I remember I was
playing brain training
and they wouldn't accept
that way of writing four.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
This is when I was like 11.
So then I started having to write fours
in the Americanized way,
which is doing that way.
- Like that?
- That's the Americanized way?
- Well, I think so, yeah.
It looks a a kind of spiky nine, right?
- I don't think I've
write any letters starting
from the bottom.
I'm always-
- Wait, how do you do your fours?
- Like this.
- I do it the opposite way, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
- So you do it from the bottom?
- Yeah, from the bottom, and then I go-
- How the fuck do you do that?
- I don't know.
- Yeah, this feels so weird.
- So in school, did you have to learn
English literature and language?
- What's the difference?
- Because they were two different
subjects for us in school.
- Oh no, we just had English.
- Shit, cause see, I had
to learn English literature
English language, Welsh
literature and Welsh language.
I fucking hated doing that many.
Okay, cause I think for us,
maybe it's just my school.
But it depended on the day of the week.
It was like on Mondays we
go through a literature
for the term that we have to study.
And then on Wednesdays we
got to do something else
watch a movie or study a
different text for a certain thing
or how to read an essay and
write an essay on Fridays.
And shit like that.
So yeah, we didn't...
I think it's because my school
was just very small as well.
So they probably wasn't
enough English teachers
in our school to be like,
"You're the literature one,
and you're the comprehension one."
- How does it feel learning a
new language as your older now
though, compared to when you were a kid.
Because I remember we had
to learn a lot of the other
languages when were in school.
We had to learn Spanish, French.
- Didn't take any of that shit-
- No.
- But it's been a really
different challenge
learning Japanese as a grown adult.
I would say.
Because I don't know, has the fact that
you are very much into Japanese culture
and watching anime helped you
at all from your perspective.
- Yeah, definitely.
I think it's made it easier,
but easy with an asterisk, right?
- Yeah.
- Easier to understand
some concepts culturally
that might explain some of the language.
Which is great.
But at the end of the
day it doesn't help me
in a crazy amount.
I think it just helps me understand
why certain things are the
way they are in a language.
You know, why you can't
be direct to someone.
Why it's always
(speaking in Japanese)
- I guess because sometimes
when you're learning
the language you're, "Why
can't I just be direct?
It's not a thing you can't do that.
That's too aggressive.
I think learning Japanese from me,
I didn't realize how much I kind of just
zoned out Japanese when
I'm watched anime before.
- Yeah, you do.
You filter it out.
because you're that's nonsense to me.
I'm focusing on this.
You're just absorbing the subtitles.
Then you kind of just
mute out the Japanese.
I didn't realize that
until I started learning.
When I actually picked out individual,
how the sentence works and how
the language actually works.
That I realized,
"Oh this didn't help me a lot at all.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
I find it really hard in my head
to recommend learning
a language to people.
Because I feel if you're
not going to actually do it,
it's kind of a waste of time.
- I know, it takes commitment.
- That's what I said to
people though, about Japanese.
- And it's one of those
things where learning Japanese
especially if you're not
going to do it full time,
it's like at least a five-year thing
that you have to commit to.
And if you quit two half years in,
- But that's the problem.
So many people.
I get fucking emails about
it all the time goddamn time,
being like. "What's the
easiest way to learn Japanese?"
There is no easy way to learn Japanese.
You just have to sit
down and just be like,
"I'm I about to commit
five to 10 years of my life
to learn this shit?"
"Yes."
Go for it.
It's like any skill chart.
Where it's the first getting
over the first real difficult bump
is the hardest.
And once you get past that,
you've gone through a challenge.
You've overcome it.
Normally you could keep going.
That's the same with any craft, right?
Voice acting as well,
photography, anything.
- YouTube.
- There's always gonna be that first point
where you think you're
starting to understand it.
Then you get to that
point where you're like,
"Fuck, I know nothing about
what I'm getting into.
- Exactly.
- And it's that point
where if you keep going
and actually start to
really put in the work
you'll probably see some results.
But a lot of people quit at that point.
- Because I'm always really paranoid
and this is true in my life.
And whenever I'm doing a
play through of a game.
When I'm doing something
and it's just sub-optimized.
Sometimes I paralyze myself.
because I'm just like,
what if I'm not doing this
the most optimal way?
Is this a waste of time?
I'm so scared of wasting my time.
So when I first started learning Japanese
I spent more time trying to figure out
the best way to learn Japanese,
than actually learning Japanese.
- It's usually like that.
- Yeah, I guess you're the
opposite to me in that sense.
Video games.
I'm definitely that.
I'll maximize the shit out of video games,
but everything else in my life like,
"That's good enough."
- I'm kind of the
opposite with video games.
I'm just video games video games...
- You are.
- Video games are just made
to be fun and time wasting.
- Yeah, because I'll
talk to Joey about videos
that we're both playing
and I'll be like, "Do you
know, this is 2% more efficient
to do this method, right?
And Joey is like, "Bro,
I don't give a fuck."
- And I'm like, "I've
already put 60L in this game,
I don't care."
- That's how with you
learning a language though
I'm like as long as I'm learning something
in the language that I can view
as somewhat useful I'm
sure it's not a waste.
- Right?
- I feel like there's no
route to learning a language.
Any bit you learn of it.
It's putting the jigsaw together.
- It depends on the person.
At the end of the day.
- Yeah, some people are crazy.
- Everyone has a different path.
Everyone learns differently
and you're not gonna discover
the best way you learn
unless you actually just go
out and fail at something.
I didn't fucking know.
I would waste a month on Duolingo.
(Joey laugh)
- I wasted a lot of time on Duolingo.
- I did.
- Other languages, European languages.
I'm pretty sure it's pretty good.
But I took Japanese.
It was not very useful.
- [indistinct] you right from the get-go
and not explaining why
you need to learn it
or what this is.
- That sounds efficient.
It was teaching me the Kanji for window.
One of the first things-
- That a difficult one too.
- Yeah, it was hard.
And see Kanji for see.
And I thought, "Why are
you teaching me this shit?"
I don't even know the Kanji from Monday.
Why would you teach me window?
I don't need to know this.
I don't even think
window is in the top 100
most used Kanji.
So why you teaching me?
- Yeah, it's pretty uncommon to see.
- I feel that the way
Duolingo went about it.
We're never gonna get a
Duolingo sponsorship by the way.
Yeah, it was, yeah, not good.
- If we do, you can call us out on that.
(all laugh)
- Duolingo is a way...
It tricks you into
thinking you're learning.
- No.
- You know a lot of just-
- Useless shit.
- Pieces of information
that you can never piece together
as a whole to use anywhere basically.
- And it's a shame,
because I feel you don't really realize
that you're being mugged off by Duolingo
until you actually start
learning it properly.
And then you're like,
"I literally have no use
for anything I learned on Duolingo,
because it was such a,
it was such a mess."
I remember distinctively.
Right?
I didn't even know how
to say any sentences.
But they were teaching
me how to read the Kanji
of Kyoto in Tokyo.
And I'm like, "That's cool.
But I don't need to know this.
I genuinely don't."
- If you go to Tokyo and Kyoto
it's written in fucking English
This is something that
I don't need to know.
What I would to know is how do I say,
"Oh I recommend this."
"I think."
I didn't know how to say,
I think or anything that.
- Duolingo, I don't need
to know if this is a pen.
I know what an Apple is.
I don't have to ask what an apple is.
- You know, there's some good stuff there.
I'm not saying it's all bad,
but I just felt the structure
was all over the place.
- Yeah, because I remember.
When we first moved...
Before we moved to Japan
Me and Connor were on
Duolingo for a good month.
Month and a half.
Before moving to Japan.
And then we got here,
and we were "Oh, we don't know shit."
So we needed to start off by
learning hiragana and Katakana.
And I remember I sat down.
And I Googled what the best
memorization techniques were.
And then I found this
memorization technique.
I can't remember what it's called.
- We'll link it in the description.
- It's like mnemonics or mnemonics.
I can't remember the
exact pronunciation of it.
And then I learnt all of
hiragana and Katakana in one day.
And then I told Connor,
"Yo, this shit works."
Connor was like, "Nah, I
don't know about this."
I linked him then same article.
And he comes back to me
three, four hours later.
I'm, "Bruh."
(all laughing)
- I can read.
- Hurrah moment.
- It was crazy.
Like I said earlier, when you go outside,
and you've unlocked the world.
Cause you can start suddenly
reading McDonald's menus
with no.
- Is the pneumonics thing where you.
It's shape based.
- Yeah.
- It would make you assign...
And to be fair, this is how
memory champions, memorize stuff
they assign stories and shapes
and objects to the memory.
And that way they can
recall them much easier.
So it would say [indistinct]
which is the one
that's like that.
They're like, "It's a chef's hat.
Think of a chef's hat when you
see this symbol for cooking.
- [indistinct] Look like a chef's hat.
(indistinct chatter)
It was yeah, it was a sign.
Because then you remember
that's kind of dumb
that it's telling you to do that.
But then you remember when you see it.
Oh, it's that dumb thing.
- Yeah.
- You remember the dumb shit.
- Yeah, I mean, it's really stupid,
but it made you remember it.
- It's Counter-intuitive right.
Because by remembering more stuff
you remember one stuff better
as opposed to just repeating
the same thing over and over.
But the best way I've
heard an explanation for it
is that your memory is kind
of a filing cabinet, right?
So if you just have one
random piece of information
that you just randomly file.
It's very hard to just find
that random piece of information.
But you have...
If that information is got a bunch
of other information that relates to that,
then it's much easier for you
to find it in your memory.
So that's why you can just
recall things a lot easier.
- Yeah.
- I definitely feel that.
I find that learning symbols for me
is way easier than learning anything else?
That's why Kanji has
been pretty fun so far.
- Yeah, you're definitely a person
who remembers stuff visually, right?
- Yeah, if you give me a set of numbers
I can normally remember
the numbers decently well.
Learning Kanji is great.
Cause I love just putting
100 symbols in a program
and just making it test me over and over
and I'll do that for hours
until I can remember all 100, right?
- Yeah.
- That's what I do, and
I find that pretty easy.
- At the end of the day, that's what
is probably the most effective, right.
It's just fucking-
- Yeah, you literally just need to force
that shit in your head.
By just doing it, doing it, doing it.
And at least the good thing
about doing that here in Japan
is that if you then
force yourself to learn
all those symbols, is
that you just walk outside
and you're like, "Oh, oh."
- Yeah, you can use it practically, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, somewhere, I'm like
I'm never going to fucking...
Why would I need to know this Kanji?
And then two seconds
later, I'm on the train
and the place has one of
the Kanjis in their name.
And I'm like, "Bruh."
- "I get it."
- My question for you, Joey,
which is, I have always been curious.
How much studying have you done?
Because a lot of people
assume that Joey's Japanese
is a second language.
And it's completely wrong.
Joey has a second first language.
- Yeah, pretty much.
A lot of people would don't know this,
but Joey's Japanese is better
than most Japanese people.
- I had no idea how
good your Japanese was.
I just kinda thought that
you were decent at it.
But then I came here, and
then you were teaching Kanji
to 40 year old people.
And then they were like, "What the fuck?
- It was in the studio.
We were doing a party
and we had three people
from our company, all Japanese.
And I was teaching them about
different Kanji structures
and shit, they were like,
"I've never heard of the shit before."
And I'm have you heard of it before?
It's so simple.
Yeah, I did a lot, a lot, a lot.
when I say I've said it in videos
but when I've said
I've studied my entire
life, I'm not joking.
I've studied my entire life.
Just to put it in perspective
when I was maybe 10 years old.
You know what I used to do for fun?
- What?
- I used to read the Kanji dictionary.
(Garnt laughing)
- Seriously?
- I was that one kid.
My parents probably thought
I was borderline autistic,
because I would sit in
my room as a 10 year old
and I'm like, "I've got
nothing better to do."
And I would just go to my mom's bookshelf
just take out this massive, you know
2000 page Kanji dictionary
and just open it up
to a random page and just
read it for hours on end.
And I dunno, maybe I don't know how much
that actually helped me in the long run
but definitely it kind of got me to
familiarize myself with
different shapes and you know
in that sense I'm
definitely a lot like Connor
where I'm very good at
learning things with visually.
- Yeah, yeah.
I need visuals.
Learning sentences and stuff,
doesn't do anything for me.
- Yeah, but another huge
thing for me was probably
the fact that my mom had this
kind of this unspoken rule
where if I spoke to her in English
I would usually get ignored.
And that's really cruel.
Especially when a four
year old is trying to talk
to their mom about something.
But I quickly picked up on it because
I was four or five years
old and I'd be like,
"Hey, mom can I do, you know, blah, blah."
She just straight up ignore me.
I'm like, "All right,
she's in a pissed off mood.
but then the more times you
experienced it, I'm like
"I have to ask her in Japanese."
The moment I asked her in Japanese,
she's like, "Yes son, what-
- That's a genius way to make
you kid learn your language.
- My mum was exactly the same actually.
She's like, "You're gonna appreciate this
when you're older.
You're getting this now, mom,
I appreciate it now that I'm older.
- Mom, I also appreciate it, thank you.
Because if she didn't do that,
then I wouldn't have just...
I wouldn't have forced
myself to learn Thai
or to use Thai in a practical setting,
which is very hard when you're not living
in the country that you're using it in.
- Exactly, you know, everybody
around me spoke English.
Because I was living in Australia.
And I had a few childhood
friends who spoke Japanese,
but because all my childhood friends
were also halfies like me.
Sometimes we just spoke
in English to one another.
So I needed a way...
I guess my mom was like,
"All right, I need to find
a consistent way for my son
to keep speaking the
language, just keep improving.
And it really helped as well
because my mum was exceedingly
good at Japanese and Kanji
and stuff that, especially.
So whenever I had a question
or I learned a new word,
I always went to my mom
and I tried to force
myself to use that new word
in a sentence.
And she would either say,
"Oh that's not how you use that word."
This is how you use it.
- You dumb little shit.
Let me tell you how to use this word.
She could immediately know
when I was trying to...
Where I was oh yeah, you just
learnt that word didn't you?
Because she'd be like,
"Okay, that's not quite how you use it.
This is how you use it."
And then I'd use it
again and she'd be like,
"Okay, perfect."
And that's just how I
learn from practicality.
- You know one big reason
I've really want to learn Japanese
is one specific series
I want to experience
after having learned Japanese.
And that's the Monogatari Series.
I've really, really wanna
experience The Monogatari Series
after learning Japanese.
Cause I love the Monogatari Series now,
but I feel like I'm getting
maybe half the enjoyment
I could be getting,
or the appreciation I could be getting.
- There's this video
I've been trying to write
for the longest time,
called You'll Never Understand Nisio Isin.
Where, because as you
said, The Monogatari Series
and everything Nisio Isin
writes is fucking phenomenal.
He's an amazing author.
A lot of it translates
pretty well into English.
But the thing that makes
Nisio Isin so amazing
is the subtleties and the
way that he plays around
with the Japanese language.
And that shit is fucking
impossible to translate.
And I've wanted to make that video
because I fucking love Nisio
Isin and the Monogatari Series
more than anybody.
But it's like how do I explain
to my English speaking audience about how
you'll never understand it.
If you're an English speaker.
That is so hard to-
- You need to have a basic
understanding of Kanji.
To understand-
- Not just Kanji, it's-
- Everything.
- He does word play in a
way that I've never seen
any Japanese author do.
And I think that's the whole reason why
so many people love him,
it's because it's like,
"Wow I didn't know that you could...
He makes Japanese people's
Japanese look dumb
That's the only way to describe it.
A Japanese person will
read that and be like,
"Wow, it's like, I don't
know this language."
Because, have you ever
seen The Monogatari Series?
- Yeah.
- I was learning Kanji the other day
and I came across Monogatari Kanji.
- Oh yeah.
- For, is it Hanase or [indistinct].
Which Kanji is it.
The one where you...
It's like to speak or to
tell a tale is like a-
- [indistinct] Yeah.
- [indistinct] one of the
meetings is to tell a tale.
- Is to tell a tale.
- And so it's like a-
- Monogatari just means thing tale.
(indistinct chatter)
- I saw it and I was like,
"That's pretty cool."
- Yeah, cause that's the thing
with the Monogatari Series.
That even the titles
are a play on the words.
Because Bakemono, and Monogatari
is two different words.
And he just mashes
those two words together
to just turn it into one thing.
- Oh okay.
- That's the brilliant
subtlety of Nisio Isin.
I don't wanna say the whole thing,
cause I wanna save them for our video.
- I was gonna ask, how is it
reading the lighting novel
compared to watching the anime?
Cause that's something I've
always been curious about.
How well the anime has been
able to translate his writing
into a visual a format.
- I think that's the one
thing I love about Shaft.
Is that they do hold this
really weird appreciation
for Nisio Isin's writing.
And that's why Anadagi's
monologues are way longer
than any anime monologue should be.
- Oh no.
- There were so much...
That why its so dialogy.
- Yeah, I just remember being like,
"What the fuck, can we just end."
- Yeah, a standard Monogatari episode
is like 95% dialogue.
But it needs to be because everything
that Nisio Isin writes is
so important to the story
because it is really convoluted.
And it does add a lot of character.
And and you know if you've
seen Monogatari episodes.
You know how every now and then
there were just these
flashing images of texts.
That's all texts ripped
straight out of the novels.
- Yeah, I was really
confused that would happen.
I was confused a lot during
every series of the Monogatari.
- Yeah, it is confusing.
I'm very surprised how big Monogatari got.
- Same.
- I remember when I first watched it
and I'm like,
"This breaks basically
every rule of filmmaking
convention that I know."
It was like oh show don't
tell, and Monogatari
is like, "How about we tell everything."
(Joey laughing)
And show basically nothing.
And you're just gonna enjoy
this 20 minute long dialogue
And it turns out amazing.
And I'm like, "Why does this work?"
I have never seen something
work so eloquently
as the Monogatari Series.
And what surprised me
is that it just became
for the Otaku culture back then,
it kind of became a cultural phenomenon.
- It did, especially in Japan because,
it was just unlike anything.
And I mean, Katanagatari
in a sense as well.
- I was gonna say, if I was a betting man,
I would have put them on
Katanagatari being way bigger than-
- Yeah.
- It's kind of weird that in the West,
it was the other way around.
People still don't really
watch I think Katanagatari
because of maybe it's like...
I don't know why you can
watch it other than illegally.
- Yeah.
- I've no idea how-
- You have to buy a $400 Blue Ray I think.
- Such a shame.
Cause it's an absolute banger of a show.
- It is fucking great.
- So good.
- Fucking great.
- It's got nothing to do
with the Monogatari Series.
Just so you know.
- It's a good thing, honestly.
- Recently there was an OVA adaptation
of the first novel that
Nisio Isin ever wrote.
I forgot what it's called.
Its Kubikiri Cycle.
That's what it's called.
There was a four episode
OVA of it that came out.
And I was okay, it's Nisio Isin,
it's essentially the series
that inspired the Monogatari Series.
So I'm like, "This has to be big."
Of course every morning
guitar fan is gonna watch it.
No one fucking watched that OVA.
And I was really sad,
because it is screaming Monogatari vibes.
- It's weird.
Cause I liked the Monogatari Series.
I don't know which part I got up to.
I watched a lot of it.
- It's like eight, nine seasons right now.
- It's just so fucking many bro.
And I'm like a monkey when I watch Anime.
I'm like, "I don't wanna
have to think about how
order and shit and what I'm
doing, just put something on.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
And sometimes I don't know what happened
in between the series sometimes.
Because it's so confusing.
There were so many times
where I would start a season
of one of that franchise.
I don't know which fucking one.
And I was like,
"Am I on the right one,
or am I just confused,
because this series?"
- That is easily the most...
That is the number one question I get,
it's probably the most.
- What's the order?
- What order should I watch
the Monogatari episode.
- It's not even that complicated.
- It's not.
- Okay, but even though if you're watching
in the right order, it's
such a confusing show
that normally you can get
halfway into the first episode
of season two, right.
You're like, "Is this season two.
I really, I really don't
know what's going on."
Then I guess I didn't have any idea
what was going on the whole time.
- That's the thing, right?
Is the Monogatari Series, one season
is already confusing enough as it is
in an enclosed story.
And when you look at it on
the grand scale of things
it's even more confusing because
basically Nisio Isin
pulled a Quentin Tarantino
Pulp Fiction.
Where everything is out of order,
but it's in the same universe.
- I mean, I don't think it
matters that much, honestly.
As long as you just get the...
Just Google with the release order.
You can't really go wrong.
- It's stressful though, man.
I've somehow fucked it up many times.
When I watch the [indistinct] Kishibe OVAs
for some reason Araki, when he wrote them
gave them episode numbers in the thing.
So when you're watching the OVAs,
they don't do them in order and Araki
never did them in order anyway,
if I remember correctly.
So you'll turn on episode
one, there'll be episode six.
And I'm like, "What? What do you mean?"
- Araki please stop.
- And you're like, "Space
bar. Fucking Google,
Which episode is episode one?"
Episode one is episode six,
episode two is episode nine.
Episode three is episode four.
And then you're like, "Why?
Why would you do this?
- They pulled a George
Lucas Star Wars right.
Episode four is the first one.
You have to understand.
- It goes episode four, five,
six, then it goes one, two-
- It's not even that, it's
just four, nine, two, seven.
It's like, "Why".
- No it's like the...
No, just Haruhi Suzumiya.
Do you watch Haruhi
Suzumiya when it was airing?
- Yeah.
- So Haruhi Suzumiya had
this broadcast order.
And it was, it was for
absolutely no reason.
It was just broadcasted
in this random order.
And people were like..
I remember when it was when it was airing,
people were like, "Oh
this is a genius move
because it's kind of like you're
piecing together the puzzle
each episode."
And now that it's all aired now,
I'm pretty sure that
they edit out the order
because the fucking last
episode chronologically
was just the most anticlimactic episode
of the entire series.
So they're like, the best
episode is episode six.
- Mix it up, mix up.
- Just mix up the order.
And people are gonna
call that genius move.
It wasn't genius, Tanigawa
Nagaru was just on crack.
- Wait, was this the
original Japanese broadcast?
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah.
- Out of order?
- Yeah.
- Why?
- Because Tanigawa Nagaru was on crack.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- I didn't know that.
See, I only watched it years after now.
I think we mentioned this before
but I watched the movie first by accident.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah
- What a dumb mistake.
- This, this guy, I think you
mentioned in episode zero.
So most people have seen it.
This person watched
The Disappearance of
Haruhi Suzumiya first.
Which is like, how do you do that.
I was still less confused
watching that movie
than I was watching
most Monogatari series.
So if you don't know they made a movie
of the thing that tied
the whole Haruhi Suzumiya.
- It was The disappearance
of Suzumiya Haruhi
which is the fourth-
- [Joey And Garnt] Novel.
- I don't know why novel.
- I don't fucking know.
All I was is like...
I had just gotten into anime.
I wanted to watch the best
rated anime movie you know.
No one told me.
- And it still is the best move.
- No one told me that I
needed a backstory, you know?
And I went into it, I watched
it all and I was like,
"Wow."
- What did you think?
Did you think it was a good movie?
- I thought it was shit,
cause I didn't know
what the fuck is happening.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- How can I think it's a good movie
when I don't know anything.
I remember being really annoyed with...
I bet Connor just watched
this, right after School Days.
And it was 10 out of 10, 10 out of 10.
What the fuck is going on?
(indistinct chatter)
- I think School Days was
what broke the camel's back.
It was definitely the
Haruhi Suzumiya movie
watching thing that
definitely made me think
reviews sucks.
- Have you gone back to watch
the movie since then or?
- No I haven't.
- You haven't.
- But you've seen the TV series now right?
- I watched watched the first
season of this TV series.
I got two episodes into
the second TV series
where they were repeating everything.
And I was just like, "No, not doing this."
- I would say that Haruhi still
is very much worth watching
in this day and age
because of Disappearance.
Disappearance is still my-
- Such a good movie.
- It's probably my favorite
anime franchise film
of all time.
- I agree.
- And up there as one of
my favorite anime films
of all time.
And this guy apparently fucking hates it.
- I think that the whole
series is kind of mediocre.
I don't know.
- Really?
- The first season was just fine.
I was watching it and I was okay,
I know this is a terrible comparison
but I was just man this just
feels Toradora, but worse.
I don't know why.
- What the fuck are you talking about?
There's zero romance in there.
- I know.
- How?
- Because the whole
setting reminded me so much
of Toradora and the
way that it was set up.
- What?
That it was et in a school.
- Yeah.
- Like every anime.
- I know this is a completely
stupid opinion on my part.
I recognize this is a garbage opinion,
but the whole time I was just like,
I guess cause it was just...
Okay, I was very bored a lot of time,
watching Haruhi Suzumiya.
The only thing that made me wanna watch it
was the fact that Crispin
Freeman, voiced Kyon.
- No that's the best part of it.
- Yeah, he was amazing.
And it was a treat watching him.
- What you said is like saying,
"Oh yeah, Anohana was kind of Another,
cause they have ghosts
in there or whatever.
- That's a fair comparison Garnt.
I mean, I don't know cause...
- They both start with A-N.
- What show can you
compare Haruhi Suzumiya to.
If you had to.
The closest comparison.
- Here's the thing, Haruhi
Suzumiya inspired a lot of...
I came after that huge...
I became an anime fan
after that huge thing
that had had its impact.
So I think I came into it
with zero attachment to it.
In any sense.
- Because I think the thing with Haruhi
that I find really interesting.
Is the fact that it's one of those anime
that is really weirdly tied to the period
that it came out in.
Much like Lucky Star I feel.
- I feel that's why I don't give a shit
about either of them.
- Because the thing is, I
fucking love both Lucky Star,
especially Lucky Star.
I think [indistinct] was fucking amazing.
But the problem is that the
references in Lucky Star
and the whole fact that
it really reflected
the Otaku culture of the 2000s,
is what made that show really funny
in the mid 2000s
But, as much as I love Lucky Star,
I can't really recommend
it to people today
because the scene has
just completely changed.
- But does that mean you can recommend
Haruhi Suzumiya today?
- Yes, I can.
- Really?
- Yeah, because-
- I think I ruined it for myself.
- I think so.
- You basically just watched the climax.
You watched the climax before
watching any of the buildup.
- Yeah.
- So now you just kind of
ruined it for yourself.
- That's why I don't
feel bad for being like
"Yeah, I think it's not that good."
Because I'm like, "I know
I ruined it for myself
and it might've been good."
I don't know.
The only way to top that experience
is if you committed to reading
all of the light novel.
- I'll be dead if I read a light novel.
I'm never reading a light novel.
- I did that, and the final,
final volume of Haruhi
was pretty fucking good.
You just have to sit down
and read nine volumes man.
- I have no interest in
reading a light novel, ever.
Because, I remember a lot
of the elements in Haruhi
have been done in other places now.
Cause there's a lot of
self-referential humor in Haruhi
and how he, I remember what
that was an innovative thing.
Remember when every fucking light novel
wasn't trying to parody
every other light novel.
And now it's just gotten so fucking lazy
with it's self-referential humor.
- Again that's the whole
thing where it comes
to the time period.
- Damn, you guys because
sound anime boomers
we had it better back then.
You should have seen the animes we had.
- In '06 when Haruhi
and Lucky Star came out.
As you said, the whole
self-referential thing.
And I think the whole
meta aspect of anime,
was just so new.
I remember-
- It was such post-modernist.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- It was so post-modern at the time.
- No, because I remember at the end
of every Lucky Star episode
while the credits were rolling
there was no ending song for Lucky Star.
What it was was it was the scenes
of all of the Lucky Star
characters in a karaoke booth.
But you were outside of the karaoke booth.
So you could only hear them.
But the conversations
that they were having
in the karaoke booth
weren't characters having a
conversation with characters
it was voice actresses
having a conversation
with voice actresses.
And people were like of course
they're voiced by voice actresses.
These aren't just characters on a screen.
They're real people.
And that meta was like,
that was fucking cool.
Cause no other anime did that.
You're laughing.
(all laughing)
- He is laughing.
- You don't understand.
- You're gonna sit down,
and you're gonna respect this culture.
You're gonna respect this Conner.
(all laughing)
- I just don't care.
- It was cool back in the day.
- Back in the day, yeah.
- I still think Meta
anime peaked Monogatari.
In terms of light novel shows, adaptations
it kind of peaked with Monogatari.
And there's been other good
light novel shows as well
that has been meta.
But I'd say, you know, Haruhi
really was the first time
I noticed it.
It was Haruhi and Lucky Star.
And then Monogatari was the
one that came afterwards
and then it kind of nothing out did it.
And now you see a lot
of lazy fucking attempts
at meta humor and meta jokes.
There was one anime I saw recently,
which was such an eye-rolling moment.
Is the the MILF Isekai
that aired last year.
- Everyone's favorite.
- It kind of marketed itself as a parody
of the Isekai genre.
Cause it's like, it's the Isekai genre.
But there's mom this time.
- It's different now.
- It's different cause
there's a mom this time.
And I remember there was one joke, okay.
They were in a hot Springs.
And there's this one sindorei
that's in the hot springs.
And then she stands up and she's naked
in front of the main character.
And then the main
character literally says,
"Ah, this is the scene where
you're about to hit me, right?"
And the sindorei goes,
"Ah, but how about if I don't hit you,
I bet you weren't
expecting that were you?"
And the main character
goes, "Ah, you're right.
I wasn't expecting that."
And the sindorei just goes off crying,
and that was the joke.
That was the joke.
- I remember we had this
exact same conversation
at the Isekai [indistinct] Video.
You were fucking fuming.
I'm like, "This is not how
you write a meta joke."
You basically explained the
meta before you told the meta.
- First of all, I want all
my anime scenes acted out
by Garnt like that.
(Garnt laughs)
Second of all, I just like...
Whereas you said you tend
to watch the trash Isekai.
I could give less of a
fuck about the Isekai
that's coming out.
- Yeah, I'm right there with you.
- It just iterates on itself
and then changes one thing.
I wouldn't be surprised if
there's another slime one,
except he's a green slime next.
And it's just like, that's
gonna be the next thing.
- That's just season two.
- It's green.
I just struggle to give a
fuck about any of the Isekai.
I wanted to watch the mum
one just for the memes.
I couldn't even muster up to type it in.
- The thing is, it wasn't
even that good for the memes.
It was you saw the title.
You're like, "Haha I can
make a meme out of this."
And then I did.
And then I watched two
episodes and I'm like,
"No, I'm done."
- Because I wanna watch these shows
so I can talk about them.
But then I realized now
maybe, I don't even know,
that six months after that show has aired
that meme is long dead.
And no one's going to mention.
- It's like by the time the
next season comes around
in three months time.
No one is fucking talking about it.
- And then maybe it would
be a factoid one day like,
"You watched the mom Isekai?"
"Yeah,"
"Oh, okay."
I mean you don't need to
watch it for any reason.
- Cause for me watching trashy Isekai
or just trash anime in general
cause apparently that's
my brand or whatever.
- It is.
- It's just the reason I do it
is because it's just
like, it's just the easy,
turn your brain off show of the season.
I have to be in a certain
mood to watch something
like Monogatari
You know what I mean?
I can't just casually sit down
having my lunch or something.
And like, "I'm gonna...
- Monogatari is the antithesis of,
"I'm just going to put something on."
You don't put Monogatari on.
- Whereas whereas with the trash Isekai,
I just sit down for lunch and
I just put it on, you know?
And I just don't have to
think, I watch it every week.
And those are the shows I end up watching.
Because they're the easiest watch.
Cause I know what I'm getting into.
I'm not being challenged.
You know, I'm just like,
"This character's going
to do that, whatever."
- How much of a brain dead
show can we make this season?
- Go on Garnt.
- Which is why I can watch them
because they are brain dead.
Because I don't have to think.
Because you know, sometimes
where you watch a good show.
And sometimes you just really
wanna be in that right mood
to watch something.
- Yeah, definitely.
- For something good.
- But with some, with the trash shows
I never have to be in a certain mood-
- That's true.
- To watch it.
Which is why I've found I've watched
more trash shows because,
sometimes I don't know.
I get anxiety sometimes when-
- It's a good show.
- If it's a good show,
but I'm not in the mood.
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
Dude, what was the show?
Keep Your Hands Off
- Eizouken.
- Right?
That was one of those
shows where I'm like,
"I can't just watch this."
- You have to commit to it.
It seems such a passionate
thing where I was like,
"I can't just, half-ass this."
I watched one episode,
and I liked what I saw.
But because of that,
I just never watched episode two
because I had to be in
that mood to watch it.
And I never was.
- It sucked because it
was really hard to stop
and then get back into it.
- Yeah, and it sucks.
Cause I know that was a good show.
I know it was, but I
just, I didn't care enough
to find that time to be like,
I wanna keep watching this."
And I feel bad cause everyone was like,
"This is the best show of the season."
I'm just sitting there watching the 100th
documentary on Netflix, you know?
Because-
- I have no time.
- I don't know.
I've had that problem a lot
more with animate recently.
- I feel you.
- This is the reason.
- This is the fucking reason
I still haven't watched
Fullmetal Alchemist, okay.
- Because you it's good.
- I know it's good.
Because here's the thing, I can go years
without watching or
reading a manga of a series
that I know I'm going to love.
But I want to be in the right mood.
And it might take years.
It might take a fucking decade.
Last year, I finally
read 20th century boys.
And it went from,
I know I was gonna read this since
I basically started getting into manga.
This is I thought, one of my
favorite mangas of all time.
And it's fucking incredible.
But I had to wait, so many years
to experience it because
I just wanted to be
in that perfect zone to read it.
And I'm so glad I did.
Because there are some shows.
Do you have some shows that
you think if you re-watch it
you won't enjoy it as much.
- Oh, yeah.
Because you're not in the same head space.
- Yeah, 100%.
- 90%, I think.
- Because I feel like,
I can never get behind
watching anime weekly.
- No, I can.
- I can't
- I can't.
- Because I'm always in a
different head space sometimes
when I'm watching a show.
- No, okay, because there's some shows
that transcend that.
There's so hype.
- Such as?
- Attack on Titan.
Watching that weekly was hype as fuck.
Every single week, no matter what,
that one day it came out.
I was hyped as shit for that show.
- Because I binged that whole series.
- It was such a good episode by episode
that even though it sucked.
It sucked to have to wait a week.
It was so good.
Cause that one day in the
week you've got a treat.
And it didn't matter how bad your mood was
or where your head space was at.
For 25 minutes, shut your brain off
and just have a fucking time.
- Man, I used to be able
to do that so easily
when I was in high school in uni.
- As well, joining in,
in the discourse online
talking about it.
- I feel that's a different side
that I never got growing up with anime,
which is the social aspects.
Because for me, it was just I watch a show
and I'm like, "That was an amazing show."
And I have no one to talk to.
- Yeah, same, same.
- The social aspect has quickly become
one of my favorite
parts of watching anime.
And it's why, I caught up to
Demon Slayer on episode 19,
cause I wanted to get involved
with the social discourse.
Cause the memes are great.
I love memes.
- The memes are great.
- It's made us so, if a show
has a bad ending or something
I still enjoy it because.
- The shit storm on Twitter.
- It's just the shit storm that follows.
- I like that shit.
- I remember when
Darling the Franxx ended.
(all laughing)
there was this shift at episode 18 or 20.
I can't remember the exact episode.
And then everyone lost their shit.
And it's not a good ending
but I had a blast watching it.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- I just realized something.
I remember when Big Ed was a thing.
Bear with me, this is gonna make sense.
Big Ed from 90 Day Fiance was the thing.
It was great memes.
Fantastic.
I went to start watching 90
Day Fiance because of that.
And I was like, "It's just not the same."
I was watching it.
And I was like, "Oh, it's cause
I need the YouTube comments
for everything.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Because it's one thing to
have a clip, it's funny.
But when there's just the perfect YouTube
thread roasting the shit out of it.
It's so funny.
And also when someone's an in a TV show
you wanna be like,
"Everyone else thinks this
guy's an asshole, right?
Let me go check the comments real quick."
Do you get this now where
you watch some YouTube videos
or clips from shows or YouTube video
where they do something in the clip
and that's the moment when
you open up the comments.
I hope everyone's talking about this.
And that's what I love
about watching anime weekly
is that you get that kind of,
everyone's gonna be
talking about that thing
that just happened on Twitter.
It's gonna be fun.
I love joining in on that.
But then you said.
"Oh, go on."
- Do you ever get personally offended
when you go on a YouTube video
and then the comments are disabled?
Even if it's something you'd never wanted
to comment on or you never...
Most of it is anime trailers
of anime repeat sometimes.
I see the comments are disabled.
I'm like, I don't know
why, but I feel offended.
- I'm just like, "You fucking pussies."
- I turn American for five seconds.
I'm like, "Free speech is dead.
Where's my second-
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Going back to what you said earlier,
if you re-watch the show
not in the right head space.
I just, for some reason I was like
"I'm pretty sure if I re
watched Darker Than Black
I wouldn't think it's that good of a show.
- No, I agree with that.
- I remember really liking that show.
And I'm happy to leave that memory.
- There's a lot of shows like that.
There a lot of shows like that..
Ergo Proxy for me is one of those.
- If I re watched a proxy.
I don't think I'd like it.
I don't think I'd it as much.
But when I watched it,
I was in that perfect-
- Right.
- Angsty, big brain boy mode.
Where it's just like, yep.
There was a lot of shows
that I'm just leaving in that bubble.
Where I'm, I'm happy to
talk about these shows,
but I never want to re-watch them.
- No, cause for me the one big
show for me is Katana Kyoukai
I watched it when I was like
in a really dark head space.
- I watched this one with the blood sword.
- No.
- That's that's Beyond the Boundary.
That's a different one.
- Okay, I thought we were talking about
Beyond the Boundary.
What are we talking about?
- He said Beyond the Boundary.
It's Katana Kyoukai.
It's Kyoukai no Katana
is Beyond the Boundary.
- Yeah, I was like,
"What the fuck is the
Japanese title of that?"
That's the one with the pink
haired girl in the glasses
with the sword.
- It's about it's the
one with the assassin
who has death eyes or whatever.
I was in a really dark head space
when I watched that.
- I've become a-
- No, it was one of those series that,
I don't wanna be that guy
but it was kind of life-changing for me.
- Okay, now we need to know.
Please explain.
How has that changed your life?
- Please elaborate.
- I don't wanna get in
too much in the detail
but I was in a head space
that I was like kind of the lowest
I've ever been in my life.
And then I watched this series
and it connected with me on a level
that nothing else could at the time.
And it kind of really
changed my perception
of the world and everything like that.
And because of it, it's
one of my favorite anime
of all the time.
But because I'm not in the same head space
that I am now that I was back then.
I'm so fucking terrified
of re watching it.
Cause if I re watch it,
and I just don't get that same connection.
Then I'm like...
I don't wanna lose that.
I don't wanna lose what
that series gave to me
at that time of my life.
And that's the one
series, that I really hold
really close to me.
And another series is actually Evangelion.
Because Evangelion, I think is one show
that is just infinitely re watchable.
Because, very time that
I've watched Evangelion,
I've got a different experience out of it.
- I 100% agree with that.
- I watched it first time
when it came out on Netflix.
First time ever watching it.
- How'd you find it?
- It was good.
I mean, I think because
it was the mega hype show
that it was.
I think you go in expecting too much.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I was always
happy with what I got.
It was just very confusing.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
That's on Anno Hideaki for you.
- He was great.
And I liked how he built the world
as a very, very terrifying one.
And I feel like a lot of
animators struggle to do that.
And a truly terrifying one.
- Do you have that one
anime, that as Garnt said
is life-changing for you?
- Yeah.
I mean, we spoke about it last episode,
which fucked up the recording by the way.
But Bokurano is definitely
one of those shows
that I think definitely changed.
Because again, I think
it was a similar thing
where I was at a point where
I think I was really confused
with what I wanted in my life.
And it really helped ground me a lot,
and really understand a lot of emotions
that I was perhaps feeling.
- Can we re-talk about Bokurano,
because I want the audience
to know about Bokurano.
- Not enough people have
seen Bokurano unfortunately.
- It's one of those shows where,
it's not the best show,
but it's a very important one
that I think people should watch.
And I don't know how to
describe that eloquently.
- It's very disturbing but not
for the conventional
reason for being disturbed.
- What Bokurano is about is,
there's these group of kids
- This is going to sound
awesome by the way.
(all laughing)
- Because it sounds like
an Evangelion rip off.
Yeah.
- It really does.
- Because there's these group of kids
and then, I think they were
on a school trip or something.
- They're on a school trip.
- All I remember is they find his cave
with a talking head or something that.
- No, so there's a guy in a cave
and he's a middle-aged man
working on a PC in a cave.
It's really weird set up.
And he basically asked them,
"Do you wanna play a game?"
- Would you to play a game?
- Which, you know, anyone
asking you that ever
with a bunch of kids is
an immediate no, no, no.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
And then I think they all
get on a scale or something.
They all take turns, he measures them.
Then whatever happens.
And then suddenly they go outside
or happens later on in that evening.
Because they were all...
We get to know these
characters a little bit.
There's how many kids is there?
12.
- It's like 12, 13.
Something that around that many kids.
And then they get teleported
into this huge mech
and there's a scary floating
head that's talking to them.
And one of the children
has to pilot the Mech.
And now we're going to go
into spoil this, a little bit.
But yeah, it's it's episode one.
So I'm going to spoil the
premise a little bit to you.
So one of the kids, pilots, the mech,
and they're finding another mech.
And it's to save the
world that they're told
before this floating head character.
- A very intimidating character.
They win the battle.
Hooray, they all win they all
celebrate and they go outside.
They stand on the mech
and then one of the kids just drops dead
and falls off the mech.
Then they find out that each
time this mech comes back
and they're summoned,
one of the kids has to pilots the mech.
And when they do, they're
gonna, die immediately after
but it's to save the world.
- Yeah, and what the
real beauty of this show
isn't really the mech
battles or the make fights.
It's more of the fact that these kids
who have to pilot the
mech to save the world.
It's basically kind of
a monster that we show.
Every week a new monster comes along.
And the new kid, another
kid from that group
has to pilot the mech.
But it's about the backstory
of each of the kids.
And just having to deal with the fact
that they're gonna die.
They're just going to die.
- And in really realistic ways as well.
These characters are very believable.
- It makes me uncomfortable,
even thinking back
to the emotions it brought out to me.
I get very...
It's a really, really brutally honest look
into the human condition and life.
And especially how, you
know, a lot of these kids
from a lot of different backgrounds.
Some of them have it easier.
I remember there's a one
kid who's the stereotypical
piece of shit.
His that spoiled..
- Of course.
- But there's some of the kids who,
I think there's one kid
who's 16 or whatever.
And he's looking after his two siblings.
It's brutal, because he's
the one who's raising
his two sisters, I think.
It's horrible, seeing
him after come to terms
with that he's not gonna be
able to look after his sister.
It's really brutal.
It's something that just
disturbs you on a level
that you can't really describe.
It's so raw, it's so realistic.
No filters whatsoever.
- It's something that
really was not many people
have watched.
It's something that was
really glossed over.
It's uncomfortable.
It's really uncomfortable
to have to sit down
and sit through.
- I admit, I definitely did not watch it
when it first came out.
I definitely gave it some time.
- It'd definitely not a, "Yo,
you watched the last episode?"
- Cause I think the problem with Bokurano,
and the reason why
so many people didn't
watch it when it came out,
is because the way that they marketed it,
was not that good, not that accurate.
A lot of people are like,
"It's a mecha.
Must just being Evangelion rip off."
- There's no world where
it's the number one anime.
cause it's just too uncomfortable.
- Yeah.
- It also came out in the time period.
Cause I think it was
the early to mid 2000s.
- It was.
- where there was just so
many Evangelion rip offs.
They they're of varying quality as well.
There's another show that
I fucking love as well,
which is Rahxephon.
- That's just an Evangelion rip off.
- I have no idea what that is.
- It's an Evangelion rip off
but it's still really good.
- It's really good.
It's totally rips off,
but it goes about it
in a totally different
way from Evangelion.
Bokurano also sits in this
category of just shows
that people have really looked over.
Cause the premise alone
sounds an Evangelion rip off.
- It does, it does.
But the way they go about it
is just absolutely harrowing.
Just seeing these stories of these kids
who have to come to terms
with their own mortality.
Cause it's a fucking tragedy.
- Yeah, it is.
- It's different from Evangelion.
Evangelion to me is just
Anno's raw cry for help.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Everyone's analyzed last
two episodes of Evangelion.
I think it's going back to that meme
about the blue curtain.
I'm fucking sure that
Ano had no fucking clue
what he was doing.
- Everyone is like, "Oh, okay,
the way that these lines move
and the way that it's very sketchy,
is like really reflective
on Shinji's mental state."
Meanwhile, Ano is just like,
"We didn't have much of a budget.
just wanna put that out there."
That's why I love about Evangelion.
Because everyone comes out of Evangelion
with something different.
Because his message was so raw
and he puts so much of
himself into the series.
That it's impossible
not to come out with it
feeling something.
- I love how with Evangelion
especially that I don't know
if it's just Anno is
just trolling like crazy.
But there were moments where
the Evangelion fan base
and the super hardcore
analysts, Evangelion
are just so committed to this idea of
everything in Evangelion,
every piece of imagery.
Everything has to have a meaning,
that I remember when Anno
finally came out in an interview
about the meaning behind Evangelion
and he just straight up
said, there is no meaning.
It's just the show I wanted to make.
And people were like, "But
what about the fact that
every time the angels die
it turns into a cross.
And he's like, "I just
thought that looked cool."
And all the analysts are
like, "No, no he's lying.
There has to be a meaning behind it."
if the creator says there's no meaning,
there's no meaning, bro.
- What's Occam's razor
where the simplest solution-
- The simplest solution
is the best solution.
- Is normally the actual solution.
- Yeah.
- And even though he indefinitely
made me uncomfortable and feel bad
for a lot of the characters.
Bokurano just went way deeper.
- I'd say Evangelion isn't from a story.
- They're not even remotely similar.
- It's not even remotely similar.
Bokurano, I feel like
has more of a structure
around its plots.
Where Evangelion just ended on this,
as I said, raw cry for help from Anno.
But Bokurano was definitely
here's a group of kids
dealing with something
that's very very uncomfortable
and you're going to feel
fucking awful watching the show.
It's not even the worst part
that kids are gonna die.
It's like, sometimes it's
their backstories are horrific.
And I'm not gonna say it,
because I don't wanna spoil it
because it's a really good one.
But there was one episode in particular.
And after I finished it,
it was one of the things
where I had to like
just sit there for five minutes
and be like, "Fuck, fuck."
I don't know if you can
remember all the episodes.
There's one or two plots.
One of the stories, where I was just like,
"Fuck, Jesus Christ."
It was right at the end.
It was the episode.
Then you think that you
expected everything, right?
Yeah.
That's what I love though
about these human drama shows.
Is that sometimes they may
just be the simplest thing
of just a story between
two people or one person.
But if it's done really well, it can be
some of the most powerful storytelling.
- I think it's more
relatable than most things.
And it's really uncomfortable to think
that you could be in a situation where
you have to come to terms with your death.
That's why I'll say this
till the end of time,
but like that's the whole
reason why my favorite
[indistinct] of all time is Inio Asano.
- I was gonna say, the one series
the one manga series
that I'm still waiting on
to be in the right head space
to read is Oyasumi Punpun.
(indistinct chatter)
Because I've read that, I've
re-read that two or three times
all the way through, and
every time, I'm just like,
"Oh no."
That's the only way it's just, "Oh, no."
Because it's just so...
It's not just Punpun as well.
Inio Asano is just so good
at writing these characters
that are just so believable.
And it's really disturbing
when you see these characters,
these very believable characters.
Run into these very believable
and horrifying situations.
And you're just ah.
If this isn't based off
a real person's life,
then that's just scary in it of itself.
Because this guy can
just think of stuff this.
And present it in a way
that is just so terrifying.
- When people are like,
man Danganrompa is really despairful.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
I'm like, "Please shut the fuck up."
It's called pink blood for fuck sake.
Real despair is uncomfortable.
Danganronpa is not fucking uncomfortable.
Sorry, I know that I-
- For my wife who died.
- You probably pissed off
so many Danganronpa fans about now.
- When you see these characters
they're about to die in
Danganronpa, it's like
who the fuck gives a shit?
- I feel that there are certain levels.
Cause everything the series
that we've talked about,
it's just like...
It hits you.
I don't wanna say it
but it hits different.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- A reason why you should watch this.
If you're like me, I'm a person who avoids
these kinds of shows the plague.
Because I cry at anything.
I cry at Dekuo when he
says anything [indistinct].
When Dekuo screams even a little bit.
I'm in tears.
I don't know why, it's a human reaction.
I'll cry at anything.
So I normally just watch shows
that I can turn my brain
off to, because I don't
want to have to get into, "Oh
fuck sake, I'm feeling it."
- I'm really scared
now, I really just want-
Now that you've said that,
I really want you to read an Inio Asano.
- I will, I know it's gonna ruin me,
and that's why I stay away from it,
but please watch Bokurano
you will not regret it.
- No, no, if you're in
the right head space
for that kind of show.
Cause you know, when you
have social barriers up
and you see something
that's sad or something.
It's yeah, you feel sad, you cry whatever.
But there are some shows
that you don't know whether
you wanna cry or just lie down.
and just disappear.
- [All] Yeah.
- Because there's plenty of romance shows
that have really left me kind of very sad.
But it's a different feeling.
- It's a different feeling.
- Golden Week made me very
sad a lot of the time.
Is that what it's called the Golden Week.
- Golden Time.
- Golden time, whatever yeah.
Golden Time, sorry.
Sorry, I'm an ape.
I liked Golden Time a lot.
And it made me very sad.
Very upset a lot of the time.
But it's just like,
I don't leave that feeling like,
"Oh man, there's no hope anymore."
- I felt the same way when
I watched Sakurasou as well.
Because that seems like all like,
Yeah, you know, cute kids in
a room just rolling stuff.
But some of the backstories
of some of these characters
I'm just like, "Fuck man."
That's the only way I can describe it.
It's just like, "Fuck man."
That's just sad dude.
But yeah, as you said.
It's sadness and despair,
are just two totally different emotions.
- Cause it's kind of those
kinds of shows where,
I use those, it changed my life kind of.
Which is really corny when you say it.
But it's just one of those
shows where you finish
and you just sit down and you
just stare at a blank wall
and you're like, "Whoa."
- Yeah, it's the big sigh, right.
- Yeah.
- It's the big sigh.
- It's the big sigh of
- You can't even listen
to the ending song.
Shit, I can't even listen to this shit.
I need to be in silence right now.
I remember being very sad
and having a similar feeling
watching BoJack Horseman.
And it taps in the same areas.
I know you're laughing.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
By the way last time we recorded this,
I said an analogy where Bokurano, right?
- The most amazing analogy.
- Bokurano to sum it up to you.
If you're familiar with BoJack Horseman.
Bokurano is imagine if
BoJack Horseman had 12 kids
and they were all equally as
fucked up as BoJack Horseman.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- And then they all had to get sacrificed
and you slowly got to hear the
backstory of these fucked up
BoJack Horseman, children.
It's so fucked up.
It's different because in
BoJack it's his own fault right.
Its all that and whatever.
It's very, very sad, okay.
It hits differently.
And I hate it.
- This episode of Trash Taste
is sponsored by Express VPN.
- Wow, we've changed shirts, Joey.
How amazing.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- I'm here to tell you
today about Express VPN.
Now I'm sure a lot of you are thinking,
"Connor, I use incognito mode.
The FBI can't see me, and you'd be wrong
in thinking that.
- Wow, call me out this Connor.
(all laugh)
- I thought incognito mode is safe me.
Wrong.
It doesn't save.
You only Express VPN can save
you and your browsing history.
As a lot of these websites can still see
your browsing history, or
your internet service provider
can see what websites you're visiting
because of your IP address.
And honestly, that's
why I never get online
Without Express VPN.
- Also the good thing
about Express VPN is that
you can bypass geo restrictions.
So say for example, I
wanna go onto Netflix
and watch I don't know Harry Potter
but it's not available
on Japanese Netflix.
So what do I do?
I tap on Express VPN.
I reroute it to the US
Netflix and boom, there it is.
All of Harry Potter.
Because sometimes I don't
want to watch anime.
I wanna watch some goddamn Harry Potter.
(all laugh)
Good thing is, if it doesn't
matter if you're on Verizon
or Comcast or whatever ISP you're on.
Express VPN will hide all the information
and all the traffic that routes
through your router from them.
So even the ISPs can't
see your browsing history.
And the thing is, it runs so
smoothly that most of the time
you don't even realize that
you have to Express VPN on.
And the best thing is
express VPN is available
on all devices.
Of course, the computer, mobile phones,
tablets, you name it.
- So you can predict your
online internet safety today
by using the number one
rated VPN service out there
by going to expressvpn.com/trashtaste
to get three months free
off of your subscription.
- That's E-X-P-R-E-S-S vpn.com/trashtaste
Yes, I'm reading this from my phone,
just in case I get the spelling wrong.
- Expressvpn.com/trashtaste to learn more,
links in the description below.
- Back to the video.
- Because I think one of
the series that I watched
that just hit really deep is this
four episodes OVA based on this novel
called No Longer Human.
Which is a classic
Japanese novel, I think.
(speaking in Japanese)
- That is probably one
of the most harrowing
things that I've watched.
- I've never heard about that.
What does it about?
- It's written by this
guy called Dazai Osamu,
who is considered one of the three greats
in traditional Japanese literature.
He was a guy from-
- The big three.
- He was.
He was the big three.
- So what's the story about in this one.
- It's been a while since I've watched it,
but I'm not sure if it's his autobiography
or if it's based on his life story.
- It's based on his life story I believe.
- So it's just based on this life story
about this guy
who just keeps taking L's man.
Imagine if you just take
L's your entire life
and you're just looking for that one win.
But no, he just keeps coming out.
You just keep taking L's your entire life.
- That sounds like The Joker.
I'm joking, I'm joking.
This guy just gets more and more depressed
as his life goes on.
Because it is based on his life story.
So this character, it's someone
who's clinically depressed.
And he's so depressed that,
you know he tries taking
his life multiple times.
With you know, a woman that he's been with
or just people that he finds.
And then he just keeps living.
Which is actually true.
The author tried committing
suicide several times
and then he succeeded.
He actually succeeded.
- He drowned himself.
- Yeah, so that's the head space
of the author who wrote this.
And the story.
- Wait, so he died?
- Yeah, yeah.
After finishing this story.
- This was the last novel he wrote
before he drowned himself.
- Oh my God.
- It's the most-
- That's one long suicide note then.
- Pretty much.
- Cause it's just a raw peek
into the head space of someone-
- This is our most depressing episode.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- I'm sorry.
- It's really good though.
It's a really good piece
of literature though.
- Because it's just
based on his life story
and all the shitty things
that happens to him.
And then it ends with
just, you think he's found
this Ray of hope, right?
You think he's found his Ray of hope
and then he just gets shit on once again.
Imagine if someone has
stage four leukemia.
And then you just find
out he has AIDS as well.
And then he gets picked on.
I then you just kick on his-
- It just keeps going.
- How it ends is that he's so...
He doesn't even think that...
If he committed suicide
that's not even the right way
to end it.
It's called No Longer Human
because he feels like...
He's so low that he's No Longer Human.
He no longer is in this human world.
And it is the most harrowing thing.
I've used harrowing a
lot because I don't know,
- It's the only way to describe-
- I don't know.
- You're essentially reading the fall.
Yeah, pretty much.
That sounds like a lot.
- It's brutal.
- It's the only way to describe it.
- I mean, I like those experiences,
but like you said earlier you have to be
in the right head space.
Because I feel like, I don't
know if you go into it,
already pretty up, you're
not feeling too great.
It's not gonna do great
for your mental health.
- I think the one problem
as well with No Longer Human
and the reason why probably
not a lot of people
know about it,
is that not just because
of it's subject matter,
but just the fact that anime
fans today know Daza Osamu
for one Bungo Stray Dogs character.
- That's true isn't it.
- Yeah, and people are
like, "Dazai, yeah he was
my husband Bungo Stray Dogs."
Not knowing that the real Dazai
was the most depressed
fucking author in probably
all of Japanese literature.
And he wrote some, not
just No Longer Human
but he wrote some amazing
pieces of literature.
Just because again, he based
it so much on his real life
and the fact that he was just
fucking depressed as hell.
- Cause I feel you have
to be in that head space
to write something that
powerful or just that raw,
that just hits and just cuts that deeply.
It's like an Edgar Allan Poe Situation.
You can't write dark poetry like that
unless you had a fucked
up life growing up.
- Yeah, it feels spoiled, you know.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
I don't have anything to worry about.
- Sorry to bring a downer to this episode.
People even watch less.
(indistinct chatter)
- But bottom line is that, you know,
regardless of the that we did talk about
a lot of light depressing
pieces of literature and media,
just because it puts you down
at the end of the day, it doesn't mean
it's something that
people should skip over.
I think that it's equally as important
to experience those kinds
of anime and literature.
- I like to do that,
so that I'm comfortable
with having those
emotions pop up sometimes.
I feel like I have at
least some experience
dealing with them.
Maybe when someone
else's it's a lot easier.
But if you do get to
that point where you are
starting to feel that, it's like,
"Okay I kind of understand
where this is coming from."
Maybe I know better how to process it.
- Yeah, a questions for you
guys going off this then
but it's a bit less depressing.
Has there been any shows or any anime
in your history that has
affected you in any way?
Not just in the negative
aspects obviously,
or just rethinking life, but just-
- Black Butler-
(all laugh)
- You definitely has a
rethink life after that one.
- I think for me, as much
as I hate to use the word
changed my life.
For me was, and this is
gonna sound cliche as fuck,
but Clannad was one of them.
(Connor and Garnt laugh)
- I know, I totally understand
where that laughter comes from.
I'm sure there was a handful of people
who laughed at the same time.
Because it's so cliche
now, to say that Clannad
changed your life.
When I watched that all the way through,
it straight up.
- That after story fucked me up.
- That was the first time that I,
not just in anime, but
in any piece of media
that I just fucking broke down crying.
Because especially that second
half of Clannad After Story.
It was just the most brutal
pain to the longest buildup.
And just, I don't think I'll be able to...
That's again going back million topics.
That's another show I
don't think I'll be able
to watch again.
Just because again, I'm
not in that head space,
and it's just something.
It's not just the fact that
it was just a sad anime,
but I think it's just the fact that
again you've been kind of
following these characters lives
all the way through.
Whereas visual novels or
romance stories would end
with the couple getting together.
Clannad took that one step further
and showed you as the
title says the after story.
Of what happens.
And I think just seeing
that made these characters
even more relatable to me.
That was the first time where I was like,
"You know what family is cool, man.
Family is fucking dope."
Before that family was just a thing you-
- Just a Christian matter of-
(indistinct chatter)
- Because before you know,
the concept of family
was just very much everybody else.
Where it's like, of course family's cool.
Yeah, everyone wants a family.
But Clannad was that one
show that really dug into
just how important family is.
And I think that, I mean,
as weird as it is to say
after I watched Clannad, I
became way close to my family.
And I think that's a big aspect
- That's pretty wholesome.
- It is wholesome.
And that really changed my life.
- I feel really bad now.
- Why?
- Because you're talking about
how can I change your life?
I couldn't fucking
finish the first season.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- That's no problem.
- I've watched Clannad and After Story.
The whole time when I was
watching Clannad, I'm like,
"When is it gonna get good?"
Don't fucking sing that Dango
song one more time bitch.
I dare you to sing that song one more-
- Cause I remember watching
the first eight episodes
and I'm just like, man
this is trying really hard.
- It's so fucking boring.
- But that's the problem.
Is that the thing with the
first season of Clannad.
I never say to people,
"Hey, you should watch the
first season of Clannad.
Because I know that on
the grand scale of things,
the first season is fucking boring.
- You can't appreciate the second season.
- That's the problem.
You can't jump into After Story
without having experienced
these characters.
And it is important.
Because a lot of these characters
do make a very significant
impact in After Story.
- But I guess, you know, it's really hard
I guess, especially now.
Maybe back then you could
make someone watch 25 episodes
of bullshit to get a good pay off.
But now you can't do that.
I just don't think you
can recommend anymore.
- Right, because the story structure
and the joke structures that pop in.
It's just so overdone now.
That it just seems like an aged version
of everything that you can see today.
But back when Clannad first
came out in 2009, I believe.
- Yeah, it was about 2007, 2009.
I think I watched it, after
I watched Haruhi Suzumiya
the first season.
And I remember thinking,
"This is just shittier in every way."
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
The school dynamic was just garbage.
- Do you just watch every high
school anime, and just like
yeah, it's in high school.
It's the same show.
- This must be good.
- I like to compare the high school anime
and see what dynamics they got going on,
and see what I'm enjoying.
Their uniform is different than before.
- This was a model in their school.
- Going off topic.
I remember the first time
I watched Seraph The End.
And I remember it was a it was a show
with a post-apocalyptic show,
about how vampires had
taken over the world.
And then for like four episodes in
there's just a fucking high school.
And I'm like, "Why is
there a high school?"
If there's one show that doesn't
need a high school dynamic,
it's fucking this show.
- I'm guilty.
Cause I'm the only guy
I think who has read
all of that manga so far.
- I'm the complete opposite of guilty.
I never consumed anything about it.
Which is so weird because
for the longest time
I don't know if you
guys got these messages.
So many people were asking to make a video
on Seraph of The End.
- It's got a really big female following.
- Yeah.
- Have you noticed I
don't think there's been
a single AniTuber that
has made a video on it.
- Because they're all dudes.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Not even the few females
we have in the [indistinct]
community have made it.
- The first episode of Zeraph of The End
was one of the best first episodes of,
I remember for a while that we had had.
It was such a good first episode.
- No, it was really good.
- World ending Wars.
And then like you said, high school.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- It gets really good again,
when they leave high school.
- It does.
- They quickly abandon that.
- And I'd to think that's
the author being like,
"Yeah, this is...
- Shit go back.
- It got really good.
And I'd say about two
thirds through the manga.
Because it hasn't finished yet.
But about two-thirds through the manga.
Where it is right now, it gets amazing.
- Yeah.
- And then it goes not so good.
Cause did the manga
deviate from the anime?
Cause I remember watching All of The Anime
and it was one of those shows where
I had a good time watching it.
- If I remember correctly, the manga
was really really similar to the show.
And they build on a lot of the things
that I thought were really
interesting in the show
amazingly in the manga as it goes on.
But then it became really weird
and world ending plot kind of trigger E.
I don't really like the final villain
that they have as well.
It's just a fine, it's fine.
- It's one of those shows where I'm like
"I had a good time watching it.
I'm not going to re watch it.
I'm probably not gonna remember
most of the stuff that happens."
- Would you recommend people
to read it or watch it?
Because I haven't done either.
- I would say watch it and
if you what you've watched
then continue onwards.
You'll going to probably enjoy it I think
up to a certain point and then
you'll start to be confused
and, it's good though.
It's good.
I like how they did a lot of things.
Sounds like the most Trump sentence ever.
I like how they did things.
(Garnt laughs)
- It means a lot to me.
- They did things, I
like the things I did.
(all laugh)
- I totally get it though.
Cause I actually agree with you.
It was good.
I had a good time.
- It's like the most 6 out of 10 ever.
It's very decent and I
have minimal complaints.
There's not much to it.
And you're just kind of like, I'm happy.
I'm happy with what happened.
And I don't want an more.
It was before I had five
Isekai to watch every season
and this just took the space of that.
- This came right after the hyper
season one of Attack of Titan.
I remember everyone was
hyped as fuck for this app.
And then it kinda fell off.
Even though I thought the anime
was pretty fucking hype.
- It just kind of just...
It just didn't take off.
And I don't know why.
- It's weird as hell because the anime
had an amazing fight scene.
An orchestrated, fight.
They were hunting down these vampires.
Really cool episode.
And for some reason
that wasn't enough hype.
- It's one of those shows that weirdly
I hear some people still talk about
but I don't really see anything about.
You know what I mean?
- Cause I think people who read it
are really, really into it.
It's good.
- I think the problem with it
is that I just kind of
liked its own identity
when it first aired.
Because I remember when it first aired
I think I made a joke that I was like,
"Oh it's Attack on Blue
Exorcist with gay vampires."
Or something along that line.
- It very much is an amalgamation
of a lot of different aspects.
And the main character
is kind of annoying.
- Yeah.
That's true as well.
- That's never a good sign.
It's annoying cause it's
like I like all of this,
but we're getting a lot of this one thing
that I'm just kind of wish it would
just be a little less potent, you know?
There's a lot of shows like that though.
I've read the manga after it
and no one really spoke about it.
And I was like, "I don't
really know why I like this."
- Like a certain Black Clover.
- I didn't read Black Clover.
- Hey man, Black Clover is good.
I'm repping Black Clover man.
- Shit, I shouldn't have said that.
He's gonna go off for 40 minutes about it.
- My monkey brain is taking over now.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Black Clover, Black Clover.
- Black Clover.
- For some reason, I
always ended up reading
the manga that no one fucking talks about
or gives a shit about.
And I don't know why I ended up...
I think because I don't know anything.
I find it more interesting.
Because no one talks about it.
- I'm definitely in that phase right now.
Where I'm just like, I just wanna find
the weirdest fucking unknown
manga and just talk about it.
- I know it's not unknown at all
but I read Terraformars just
because no one speaks about it.
And I remember liking
what I saw of the anime,
which is funny cause the
anime adaptation was horrible.
But I remember enjoying the concepts.
So I went back and read all of it.
and I had a fucking great time.
Terraformars is awesome.
- It's amazing.
- You should definitely read
it if you get the chance.
Super gory, terrifying cockroaches.
Great time.
- Really good.
(Joey laughs)
- If you've seen the
thumbnail that Connor has made
about his cockroach story,
that's a Terraformar cockroach.
- No, let me give you a
32nd pitch on Terraformars.
There's an expedition to Mars,
and there's these cockroaches
that are absolute giga
charged cockroaches.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
Gym bro cockroaches.
And then they wanna
bring them back to earth
to see why they're like this,
who made these cockroaches like this.
Because there must be some reason.
- Why are they so chad?
- And then it turns out
that these guys can fight.
And then did humans get
injected with bug DNA,
insect DNA to become super humans,
but then they still keep getting destroyed
by the giga charged cockroaches.
And it's just a great war.
It's a great time.
Lots of politics.
Lots of Game of Thrones
politics-esk things involved.
It's fantastic.
- Lots of deaths.
- Yeah, it's great.
Because you would think that
a really straightforward plot
where it's about action, big
cockroach fight, big bug boy.
But then it just suddenly...
But then it really quickly...
- Big bug boys.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- That's such a perfect
way to describe it.
- Bug boy.
- You be bug boy.
- You don't ever feel as
excited for learning one bug.
cause I remember, I remember thinking
when I was in high
school the mantis shrimp,
coolest bug in the world.
You know what the mantis shrimp is?
- Is that a bug?
- Is that the one that punches.
- It punch, the speed of
sound and it punches so hard
that it can't be contained in aquarium.
- I remember that chapter.
- This thing is tiny.
And then when they made a human
formed with a mantis shrimp,
I was bro, bro, I know what that is.
And then yeah, he was RP.
He was pretty strong.
But I've gone off topic.
But because I remember thinking.
You read 80 chapters of this thing,
thinking that it's just gonna
be big man punch bug man.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- I'm like, that's fine.
Cause you're down frame.
Then it quickly turns into, but wait,
if earth was trying to take
over Mars and get these samples
there would be a lot
of up politics involved
with which country is gonna want what.
And so it divulges into a lot of that.
And it's really fucking interesting
- The wall building has done really well.
- It's super fucking good.
I really recommend it.
Sorry that turned from a 32nd
pitch into a whole discussion
but it's a great manga.
And if you, if you something
Gantz, something like that,
you'll probably go
right ahead and view it.
I think I've read it,
just after I read Gantz.
Cause I was looking for some very-
- Perfect for that kind of-
- I was in the edgy teenager phase.
- I was literally living
my edgy teenager phase,
like six months ago.
I read Gantz, I read Terraformars .
- Yeah, sometimes, the edgy teenager phase
you never grow out of it.
I fucking love going back
to my edgy teenager phase
because I really wanna
reread Gantz as well.
Gantz is fucking great.
That defined what I was into
as a late teen.
- It's so good, Gantz.
- It's like aliens, sexy girls, gore.
Sign me up baby.
- Okay, there's a scene in Gantz.
And I guess because we're used
to the normal dynamics in anime.
Where they're like,
"Oh, a hot girl turn up
and he wants to have sex with her."
But then he actually
just starts fucking her.
- Yeah, he just starts fucking her.
I'm like, "Who is this chad?"
I've never seen such a
big chad in anime before
what the fuck.
- I was on the train,
reading this as well.
That was a terrible manga
to read on the train.
Cause every time I'd flick the panel,
it'll just be naked tits and stuff.
- That sex scene The manga is so long.
It's so long.
- It's so weird that it's
like not even remotely
a realistic depiction of sex.
It's so weak then suddenly she's
obsessed with him after it.
It's so fucking dumb.
But the one thing that's
amazing about Gantz
and I would to sell people on
is one the monster drawings
and the level of detail.
- This is why you do not want
to watch the anime at all.
- Cause Gantz is peak mid 2000 Gonzo CG.
You think CG today is bad.
Watch, Gantz, and you just
see how bad CG was back then.
- I just remember just the
absolutely just messed up CG
of even the opening.
Where it's just like,
let's see how many times
we can rotate this camera.
Make everybody sick.
- I'll put that on the screen
right now, so you can see.
- The opening was a banger.
Oh, that song was so good.
(indistinct chatter)
Every time I watched it, I was like,
"I'm about to throw up."
It's so dizzying.
- If you enjoyed the good
parts of Darling and the Franks
the mystery and not knowing
anything about the world
and wondering, "Oh my God,
how does this all function?"
If you like that aspect of world
building you'll love Gantz.
- Yeah, I was really impressed,
by world building in Gantz,
because not to spoil how it ends,
but the actual ending of Gantz itself
was very very anticlimactic.
- Questionable.
- But the actual answers was like,
that kind of was that you
know that big brain meme.
That was, "Oh my God."
It's fucking great.
It's one of the few series that I've seen
that has built up this huge mystery
and has delivered on it.
And has delivered on a answer that.
It's satisfying.
- The actual ending is not great,
but the answers for the main
mysteries were very satisfying.
So it doesn't end amazingly,
but the explanation for all the stuff
that was happening is very cool.
And I thought it was really interesting.
But there's also some stuff in the manga
that did not age well.
- Like what?
You don't wanna say.
Everyone who's read it
will know what I mean.
But yeah, there's a part where
a character does black face
and suddenly turns-
- Oh my God, I completely
forgot about that.
(indistinct chatter)
- I read it six months ago.
And there's a scene where
one of the characters
goes to shoot up a thing in public.
He goes to do a public shooting.
- Oh my God.
- It's really really bad.
Its awful.
- That is the most yikes moment I've ever-
- Please don't cancel Oku Hiroya, please.
- Because it's a normal Japanese guy
and then he wears blackface
but then he's just drawn
like an actual black guy.
And it's really, really
uncomfortable to read.
Cause you're like...
"I don't really know."
And that was the moment
where I went online,
to be like has anyone else
realized how fucked up.
And then immediately everyone was like,
"You know it's good."
- We kind of turn a blind eye on it.
- Its the one thing that
makes it really hard
to recommend, because it's
a very interesting series
and it does a lot of cool things,
but then it's really, really fucked.
That part is you kind of
wish that wasn't there.
Because then you could
recommend it to edge people.
- [Joey and Garnt] Yeah.
- It's just too much.
- It's just an example of
something that has an aged well.
Cause when I read that as a kid.
- There's a lot of nuance that
is lost in Japanese culture
and that kind of stuff.
It's still, even for Japanese
standards is pretty awful.
- It was, yeah.
When Gantz was serializing.
It was very lopsided in
terms of, is this okay
or is this not okay.
- Do you know if the Japanese
audience is concerned
with it being racist?
It's like, I don't know.
It's definitely the one giant
stain on Gantz in general.
- I think so.
Other than the 3D CG.
(all laugh)
- That's a pretty damn, I
mean, that's just the stain
- That's just the shit stain on the-
and they have a live action movie.
Didn't they?
- Yeah.
- But the live action was not as horrible
as a lot of people
thought it was gonna be.
Ca use I watched the live action.
and I was like, it wasn't amazing.
Solid 5 out of 10.
But , there was definitely
a lot of questionable CG
about it because of course
Japanese live actions.
- Obviously.
But the way that they actually
did the whole Gantz thing
and the whole feel of it.
The whole despair of, shit, this wall
we don't know what the fuck is happening.
They did that really
well in the live action.
- What do you think is the
best live action anime movie?
'cause that's hard.
- I wanna say, I know, which one it is.
- Which one is for you Gintama?
- Yeah.
- I'm not familiar with Gintama.
- The Gintama live action.
I've never laughed that
hard watching a live action.
And not talking about
Dragonball Evolution,
ironic laughing.
It's genuinely-
- Funny.
- It brings out the Gin Tama
spirit, so fucking well.
And I don't know how the hell they did it,
because you read a Mana like Gin Tama
or watch an anime like Gin Tama.
And you're there's no way
this can be live action.
no fucking way.
You can't translate this
comedy into live action.
But they somehow did it.
- The mat lads did it.
(all laugh)
I'm like the casting was perfect.
The costumes were perfect.
- I'll take your word for
it, cause I have no idea.
- Even the action scenes,
because the second half of it
goes into the first story arc of Gin Tama.
And concludes it.
And I'm like, wow, this
is actually really good CG
and really good choreography.
And it's very believable ginta movie.
I would watch that again.
That's how good it is.
- I was pleasantly surprised
with the Jojo part four movie.
- Really?
I didn't like it.
- It was fine.
I thought some of the
scenes they did pretty good.
- That's the thing with
live-action anime movies.
The bar is so low that just
(indistinct chatter)
- Is it good compared
to all these other shit
or is it just genuinely good.
- Being passable is the best compliment
you can give an anime live action.
I remember watching the ghost
in the shell live action.
And I remember how
offensively average it was.
- I couldn't form an opinion on it.
Because I'm just like, "It's okay."
- The ghost in the show was really weird
because it's if you watched it as a ghost
in the show live action,
it was a four out of 10.
But if you just watched it as like...
If you just thought okay this
is just a standalone, scifi-
- Complex.
- Yeah.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
bring brain references.
- You know what, I watched
Alita the Battle Angel
was really good.
And you totally forget it's a manga.
- Did you think it was good?
- I thought it was pretty good.
- I thought it was kind of shit.
- I think that's one of the best animated
or manga movies we've had.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I mean, the ending was just whack man.
- Yeah, but I mean, everything
up until the ending was-
- For me, Alita was very
much Ghost in The Shell.
- No, I put it higher
than Ghost in The Shell.
- Have you read Alita?
- No, who the fuck has read Alita?
- I have, that's why I watched the movie.
- Joey has read everything.
- That why I've watched the movie.
- Yeah, I bet, if I watched
the manga I'd like it.
- Yeah, very much like Ghost in The Shell.
- I bet if I read the manga
I'd like the manga more.
- It's like Ghost in the Shell .
People who are fans of Ghost in The Shell
before they watched live action,
that was a shit adaptation
of Ghost in the Show.
Alita is the exact same.
It's good as a standalone movie.
But as an adaptation of
Alita it was pretty weak.
But at least the Hollywood one is better
than the Japanese adaptation.
- Yeah, I mean.
- Did you watch the attack on Titan.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, oh my God.
- What's with them being Nazis.
What's with that?
- I got invited by Madman in
Australia to go to the cinemas
on the day, premier day.
They were like, "You
can bring a plus one."
So I brought my best friend.
Who's a huge anime fan and we watched it.
And we just kind of sat there
as the credits were rolling.
And I just looked over and
I'm like, "How was that?"
And my friend's like, I
know you got me in for free,
but I want my money back."
(Garnt laughs)
I'm like, you what I kind of have to agree
with you there man.
- Because my cousin who I've been trying
to get into anime for ages.
Biggest norma, you can kind of think of.
- Breaking bad.
- I was, recommending Attack on Titans.
Because that's one of the perfect-
(indistinct chatter)
It's Attack on Titans.
And then he fucking ends up watching
the attack on Titan live action.
And he is like, "Yeah,
that wasn't very good."
I'm like, "You were almost there.
You're this close."
And now whenever I
recommended Attack on Titan.
Am like, trust me the
anime is so much better.
He's like, "But is it the same story?"
But you don't get it.
- You might not know,
but there's this character called Levi.
He wasn't in the live action
because they couldn't pronounce his name.
- You know that's the reason
why they cut him out right.
- Really?
The reason why Levi's
known in the live action
is because they were like,
"These are Japanese actors.
I don't think they can
pronounce the V sound."
And I'm, "You do realize this was written
by a Japanese person."
- People like that are
the reason why microwave's
come with instructions.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- They need a hand to hold.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God, you watched the movie.
Oh my God.
- How'd you fuck up this bad.
- How is he fucking this up?
Man, I kind of just stay
away from the movies.
I just stay away from all my movies.
- I think the only one I've
enjoyed is Edge of Tomorrow.
Which I didn't-
- That one was really good.
- Tom Hanks?
- Tom Hanks.
Tom cruise.
- Fucking Tom Cruise.
- Tom Cruise.
- If it was Tom Hanks, I
would have [indistinct].
- Cause I didn't even realize
that was based on a manga.
- Yeah, it's All You Need is Kill.
- Which is like the edgiest title ever
All You Need is Kill.
- Coming to you next summer.
- It's actually based off a novel
that was then later adapted into a manga.
That was written by Obata Takeshi.
It's the illustrator for Death Note.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah, which is also very good manga.
So when I saw, cause I picked up the novel
while I was in Japan.
Because I was just like,
"All You Need is Kill.
Fuck yeah, dude, that sounds awesome."
And I read it and the
novel was really good.
But then, when they were
promoting in the bookstore
they were like, "Tom Cruise
movie coming out soon."
I was just like, "Oh no.
Oh, don't do this.
Please, please, Tom.
Don't do this."
But of course I had to go watch it.
Cause I'm like all right,
"This is probably gonna be shit,
let's go watch it."
I was like, "All right, you know what,
- It was good.
- I'll give you this one Hollywood.
You did good.
- It was one of the few
films that I watched it.
And I was like, "Oh I gotta go
read the source material now.
And it was quite different
from the source material.
It wasn't exactly the same.
But that's how you adapt a live
action movie in my opinion,
you've gotta change some things.
If there was something that is just...
If there's a concept in
a story that you know,
will never work in live action.
Don't put it in.
It's so simple.
And yet there are so
many fucking productions
and directors who are like,
"No, we can do it.
No, we can definitely."
Assassination Classroom, giant yellow guy.
Fucking man CG will fix that.
- That was a weird adaptation.
- I don't know why, but I've
slowly started to find myself
watching live action, animated movies.
- Why, why?
- Why would you do this to yourself?
- Because it's just-
- You're gonna give me shit
for watching [indistinct].
- It's just a guilty pleasure for me now.
Even if it's...
Because I watched the
Erased live action as well.
And even though I didn't like Erased.
- That was on Netflix, right?
- Yeah.
But purely just because,
it's the perfect example of
curiosity killed the cat.
Right?
Because I'm just so curious to be like,
"How could they possibly adapt this?"
And then I go into it, and I'm like,
"Amazing, I just wasted an
hour and a half of my life."
- There are just some animated actions,
you just know are gonna be shit.
There's some you watch for the train wreck
but not all of them.
Like Erased, you don't need to watch.
The Full Metal Alchemist live action.
I don't need to watch that to
know it's going to be shit.
- Yeah, that's the one thing
I still haven't watched.
- You know what I'm gonna do?
- The definite one is-
(indistinct chatter)
I'm just gonna watch the
live action movie now.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
And you'll be guys, Metal of
the Alchemist isn't that good?
- What the fuck are you talking?
It sucks.
Full Metal Alchemist sucks.
What were you guys on?
- We should please do that.
- No, please don't, please don't.
You will actually ruin
the story for yourself.
You'll get a speed run story.
It's just awful.
I mean, the only reason I
watched the Death Note one.
- The Death Note one.
Is because, you know, I
wanted to be able to help
with the discussion on Twitter and-
- Oh yeah.
- I mean, I got a great video out of it.
- Yeah, exactly, right.
You can clown on it.
It's great.
Because everyone's
gonna be waiting for it.
But you can't clown The Erased one
because no one gives a fuck.
- Well, that's why I
didn't make a video on it.
- Why watch it, why
waste an hour and a half.
Why, why?
I mean, I've done that.
I think there are more anime live-action
that I haven't made a video on
than ones that I haven't made a video on.
Just because no one needs
to know this is shit.
I just need to know this is shit.
I don't need to share this,
because everybody already knows it's shit.
I didn't have to make a video
on The Parasite live action.
Because everybody knew
it was gonna be shit.
But I needed to know that
it was gonna to be shit.
And sure enough, I found out
that it was absolutely garbage.
- You know what blows my mind,
that sometimes they
may only make the anime
to promote the garbage movie.
With Parasite one of those situations.
I know Kaiji, the gambler one.
That was definitely a...
That anime was just made
to promote the movie.
- Yeah.
- It was it?
- It was.
- And the movie was...
- The movie was questionable.
- I mean, actually...
I enjoyed the Kaiji movie
in this really campy kind of way.
You know what I mean?
- But in what world would
you choose the movie
over the anime?
Oh no, absolutely not.
- Absolutely not.
- Because watching, watching
the Kaiji live action
was kind of just watching
some K drama or J drama.
- So, do you want to explain what Kaiji is
quickly to the audience.
- Yeah, so, it's a gambling story.
So this guy racks up this
massive, massive debt.
I forgot why he even
racked up this massive debt
I can't remember why he did it.
- It's for some reason.
- So, so basically he gets an offer
from this mysterious company
that can clear his debt.
That just says, "You
need to go on the ship
and you're gonna play a bunch of games.
And if you win these games,
then we will clear your debt.
Or you can go into even greater debt.
And the basic premise is
just Kaiji on the ship
or just after the ship parks over,
it's just him going through
a bunch of different gambling games
and just trying to clear his debt.
- And he's not OP.
So that's the best part,
is that you genuinely...
He loses a lot.
He loses as much as he wins.
And it's great because
you genuinely don't know
if he's gonna lose or win every day.
It's a very quotable show.
- A lot of people didn't watch it.
I think mainly because for some reason
it was only published in for ADP.
- Really?
- Do you remember that?
- It was only published in 40P.
- It came out in 2007 as
well, it only for ADP.
And I remember when I was watching it
I'm like, "Where's the-
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
Just know that when you watch
it it's gonna to be like that.
But it's definitely worth your time.
- I thought the reason why
people didn't watch Kaiji
was because of the art style.
- I think is that.
And I think there's a ton of reasons
why people don't watch it
- It's got zero female
characters in it, I think.
I can't remember a
single female character.
- It's got a lot of ugly
bastards in it, I know that.
(Garnt laughs)
That was the one show
that has more ugly bastards than hentai.
- That's Kaiji, right.
Imagine an NTR plot, but instead of sex
it's just watching a guy-
- It's just gambling.
- It's just NTR gambling.
That's just Kaiji, okay.
(Joey laughs)
- But it's fucking great.
- It's so good.
Going from watching Kaiji to,
I don't know how you
pronounce it, Kakegurui.
- Kakegurui, yeah.
- It was like, how can I watch this shit,
when this gambling is so fake?
it's all just gambling to serve the plot
whereas in Kaiji, it felt real gambling.
- Yeah, Kakegurui was just they threw ...
They were like,
"Okay, how do we make
these hot girls orgasm?
Gambling.
Let's just throw in."
- The main character always wins.
Unless it doesn't really matter.
Then she doesn't win.
And it's like, "Haha,
you didn't expect that."
It's like, "Yeah, but it didn't matter."
- Yeah, exactly.
There was the one dumb moment.
That's the part I dropped the series.
Was when the girl with the
gun playing Russian roulette
and it's like it's obvious
no one is going to die
in this situation.
Don't pretend like someone is going to die
because I'm not stupid.
And then I couldn't watch it further.
Cause I'm like, "This is just dumb."
- Whereas if that was in Kaiji,
- Someone's gonna die.
- [Joey and Garnt] Someones gonna die.
- Which is great, but then it wasn't sure,
maybe both of them could die.
We don't know.
That's the best part about Kaiji.
Is that you just genuinely don't know.
- No, the best part of Kaiji
is the narrator's voice.
- Oh yeah.
(indistinct chatter)
- Why is there just that narrator
in every fucking show of that time.
- Because it's so epic.
I love it.
- Because I only see it an anime.
You're not watching this
Netflix show and this narrator
comes out, you know what I mean?
- Dude, what's the follow-up series?
The spinoff one with the
middle management, whatever,
Tonegawa.
Tonegawa, maybe.
- I never watched that
one, was that any good?
- It's quite funny.
If you go in expecting Kaiji,
you're gonna be very disappointed.
- If you want Kaiji, then
it's better if you read.
I dunno the author's name,
but read some of his other works.
- Akagi is really good.
- Akagi.
Akagi, is basically Mahjong Kaiji.
Here's the thing, I had
no interest in Mahjong.
I was watching the show.
I had no fucking rules...
I had no clue of the
rules of Mahjong either.
You get drawn in right.
- But after I finished Akagi,
I was like, man, maybe I should
learn how to play Mahjong.
This looks fun.
- I had the exact same thing.
I don't know which show was it.
It was a little girls competing
in mahjong tournaments.
I think it might've just
been called Mahjong.
- Maybe, I don't know, yeah.
- I don't know what it was, but I remember
I was trying my goddamn
best to learn Mahjong.
And I was like...
- There a lot of shows like that.
Well, I mean you know,
March Comes in Like a Lion,
made me really invested in Shogi.
I was like, I don't know
what the fuck Shogi is.
But then after I watched
March Comes in Like a Lion.
- I wanna learn Shogi.
- Man, I kind of wanna learn Shogi.
Shogi is just Japanese chess right.
- Yeah, I know, I'm good at
chess, I wanna be good at that.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I don't even know how to play chess.
And yet I was like, Shogi looks fun.
- What?
- I was like, I don't know
how to play chess Joey.
- Because of, I just didn't.
We didn't even own a
chess board in my house.
- You know how to play chess, right?
- Yeah, I know the basics.
- That's good.
- I fucking suck at it.
I haven't played in years
- We need a chess anime, but
obviously, because Shogi-
- No, because I actually
really want a chess anime.
- That would be so good in anime.
- It would be so fucking hype in anime.
- I'm surprised there hasn't been one yet.
- Is because how big is Chess in Japan?
It's not very big.
- I mean, I guess if
you're gonna play chess,
you might as well play Shogi, right.
- No, because I think a
lot of the grandmasters
are from Japan.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah, that's true actually.
Because I remember I got
sucked into this YouTube hole
of just watching a lot of chess.
I had no interest in chess.
I'm like, "Man, this is
actually really interesting."
Cause the history and
just the entire premise
of chess is really, really interesting.
The fact that you-
- There's a history around chess.
- It's basically this
massive tournament arc.
you know what I mean?
And there's reading about
some the most historical chess games.
I have no interest in chess,
but this was fucking hype.
And I remember thinking,
man this would work so well
in an anime or manga setting.
So I went out to try and find
a single chess anime or manga.
And there just wasn't one.
I was really, really disappointed.
- It's surprising
honestly, because I think
the whole stereotype with
chess in anime is like
you know, the transfer
student who also happens to be
the daughter of the giant companies.
Like, "Let me just do
a little bit of chess
on the side line.
The way chess is used in anime
is to make someone look smart.
Like, there's no reason
for Lelouch to play chess.
- I was about to say that.
- Because he's a tactical genius.
- Yeah, he's a tactical genius.
- Do you ever lead with the King Connor?
- No, you never lead with the King.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Do you wanna tell
people about your hidden-
- That's you're a chess champion.
- When I was 13 or 12 or I
just started high school.
It was after I left primary school.
I was playing professional chess.
And how I ended up
playing professional chess
was weird to begin with.
Cause I never played it much.
I just liked video games a lot.
Yeah.
It was the only video game
that my dad would play with me is chess.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
So cause if I wanted-
- EChess.
- No, normal chess.
But I remember I was
playing at year three.
How old are you in year three
in the UK, like eight, nine.
- Eight, nine.
- And the chess club is
only for the last year,
which was all the 12 year olds.
And I remember they wouldn't
let me play with them,
but one they let me play with
them and it's just so anime.
Cause outside of the chess club
I beat their best player
in a game of chess.
Then they were like, "No, no
you've got to let this guy
play with us his good."
So I beat them all, and
then nothing happened
for three years until it was
my time to join the chess club
and I was allowed to join the club.
And then I joined the chess club.
And our school had lost every
single chess tournament ever.
Because it was a local...
I didn't even know we had this.
There was a local circuit, right.
Between all the schools played each other,
like football and every other sport.
There's one for chess.
And I remember that we
started playing in that
and also the guy who is
number two in our chess team,
because I was number
one, we were both equal,
which is also very anime.
- Rival character in everything.
- He's power level was on par with mine.
- My whole chess experience
is genuinely an anime.
I'm gonna keep talking and
there's more stuff to it.
And then we just started
winning every single game
against every other school.
It wasn't even close.
I remember these kids were bad.
(all laugh)
And I remember every time
they would be shocked
at how quickly we would beat these kids.
Cause, it's very different
in professional chess
to playing if somebody doesn't...
In professional chess, it's a long thing
and I'll get more into it later.
These were games I
could win in 20 minutes.
Because I can see how they
fucked up and I would take it.
To me, it just made sense.
I didn't practice.
I was just good at
games and it made sense.
And then one time there was a school
and these guys had been
number one for like 10 years
in a row or something.
Cause they had a guy
who was someone's parent
and he's obsessed with chess.
Very, very good at chess.
And we beat his team.
And they were shocked.
They were like, "Not me,
you beat the protege team.
- This is a sports anime.
This is a fucking sports anime.
- You could base a chess manga
off of your life honestly.
- I remember thinking it
was weird because this guy
was making like a whole...
Bear in mind, I was 12, I didn't know
what the fuck was going on.
And this guy is making a whole commotion.
He was shocked.
And I was sitting there and he was like,
"Walk me through everything you did."
And I was like, "I don't know.
I didn't write it down."
Because most you're
supposed to write it down
in professional chess.
And he was writing it down
and I thought that was weird.
I was like, "Why don't
you write down your moves?
You just did them.
You're not gonna go back.
And he was like, "Why did you move here?
How did you know how
to do that and stuff?"
And I was like, "I don't
know, I just did it."
And then he spoke to my mom, and was like,
"You should come to this thing."
It's weird.
It's 200 kids come to a place.
By the way, chess for kids is
a really weird kind of thing.
It's just adults pushing a bunch
of Cambridge kids to do it.
So I went to a location
and that was 2, 300 kids,
all just playing chess.
Then you would get an opponent.
And if you won to lost,
you would then play someone who has won.
And the more you kept winning,
the more you would go up.
And eventually people
who won all their games
would go on to play for the area.
- It's like a legit tournament.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Legit.
Here's the best [indistinct].
I was killing all my games, right.
And I had won four.
So you play seven.
I remember I won four in a row.
They were really easy.
My friend as well, he'd lost two
and then he was already
out and I felt bad.
I was like,
(indistinct chatter)
- I'll go on for you friend.
- I'll see you in the finals.
(all laugh)
- And then it's weird.
Cause I never had any...
A lot of these kids as well.
They would be studying
it in between games,
but I would just whip out
Pokemon at start playing it.
Then I'll be like, "It's my
time to go and save and play."
But I remember, so my fifth game,
was against the guy, I beat in my school.
The prodigy team or whatever.
And I had to play him again and we drew.
It was really anti-climactic.
I was like, "Fuck, I beat him last time,
I wanna beat him again."
Anyway, I got on the team and I was okay.
I was struggling.
Cause this is where it was
getting really serious.
I was decent enough where I
could win 70% of my games,
but it was still starting
to get really long.
Because chess games never
went more than an hour.
And then they start becoming two hours.
And I'm 13.
And like, "This is [indistinct]."
- I just want to play-
(indistinct chatter)
I start winning and then I got
content and they were like,
"Hey, do you wanna play for your country?"
And I was like, "Sure, I guess
I'll play for my country."
Why not?
Yeah, I'm doing good enough.
So I turn up, I go to
the first tournament.
You won't believe because I was number 10.
So there's 10 seats.
1 is the best 10 is the worst.
So I was the worst on the country.
Worst for the country for team.
Guess who was number one.
I think I've told you guys this story.
It was the main bully at my school.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
I shit you not.
- You can't make this shit up.
You can't make this shit up.
- I shit you not, it was
the main bully at my school
who no one knew he did this.
- This is the point in the manga
where the flashback begins.
- Yeah.
- He used to bully me.
- He was the main rival all along.
- He literally was the kid
that everyone was scared of.
And I remember thinking man,
he was really good at Halo Wars too.
That was weird.
Then suddenly he's really good at chess.
He was amazing, and he
was winning a lot against
really really good players.
Bear in mind, when it got to this point
it was pretty much me, him and eight kids
who were gonna go to Cambridge.
You know what I mean?
The environment was really weird as well.
And I remember just, that
was when I really started
to not enjoy chess anymore.
Is that when I remember,
when I lost the game,
I got fucked bollocked by the coaches.
They were furious at me, because
they would take your sheet.
Because this is when you had
to start writing it down,
they would take your sheet,
and they would rinse you for your moves.
And then they would
watch you the whole game.
So that's always an area above
where they can watch you.
(indistinct chatter)
I remember if you made a move,
that was under five minutes.
That was a mistake.
You've got rinsed for it.
Because they were like, "You
didn't think long enough."
- Wow.
- You've gotta go through the options.
Because it gets to the
point where you're like,
you know that they're
thinking just as many moves
ahead as you are and it's
starting to get really difficult.
Because you're like, "Fuck,
I haven't studied enough
at this point."
Because I never studied chess.
But this is where I was
getting to the point where,
I was against people who
are naturally pretty good
but also were studying
all the fucking time.
And it's just a really bad environment.
I really didn't like it.
I would finish my games
and I'd play Pokemon.
They would wanna talk about,
so why did you move rook
to F2, why did you do that?
Because he was really
impressive when he moved his...
And I was like, "I don't."
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
We are playing chess
for eight hours today.
I do not wanna talk about
chess in between my games.
It was just a really...
Yeah, it was a really weird environment.
I think, if I came into
chess later in my life
I would've had a more
healthy enjoyment of chess.
I still like to play it occasionally,
but I think I'm just scarred
from the anime experience
that I had.
(Joey laughs)
- Cause that's what I find
so fascinating about chess,
is just talking to you and hearing
about your chess story and
reading up and watching
Magnus Carlsen I think that's his name.
- Yeah, Magnus Carlsen, his one the best.
- His story and how you were just like...
You were just born and
you just got the game.
There are people who
just studied the game.
And then there are just
people who just are geniuses
and they don't know why.
It's fucking fascinating.
It's fucking fascinating to me.
- It was weird because you kind of...
No matter how good you are at something,
and how much raw talent
you have at something.
When you start competing
at such a high level,
you start to realize that
it doesn't matter as much,
but also you meet people who also...
There might be 10 people in that country.
Who also have that same raw talent.
And then it's like fuck.
Cause then it starts to
come to who can put them.
Cause I didn't care about chess.
I never cared about chess.
I was just good at it,
and I just played it.
- Such a thing that a
protagonist would say.
(all laugh)
I never cared about chess.
- Whereas the protagonist
would have got to my point lost
and then been like, "I'm gonna
to dedicate my life to...
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
I was like, "Pokemon Ranger just came out,
so I'm gonna start spinning around that.
- Yeah, you took the [indistinct] route.
Where you're just like, "I
lost, end of the manga."
- And it was just kinda like...
It gets to that point in
your life, where you're like,
I don't need this anymore.
I remember my parents are so sad.
I don't know why my parents
were so invested in it.
I think it was a mixture of proud
and also they love bragging about it.
Why wouldn't you do that?
- Yeah, of course.
- Your series got
canceled from poor sales.
(all laugh)
- I had a spin off.
So what happened is about
when I was 16 or 17,
I had a rejuvenation of my enjoyment.
Do you remember a website
called MLG Game Battles?
- I remember that.
- It was where you could
compete against cob,
but also Yahoo Chess.
I remember, I would compete
against fully grown men
and beat them on Yahoo Chess.
They'd get so pissed off.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
and then joined the local pub,
and that was a weird experience.
So I joined the local pub
chest team and I remember...
bear in mind they were all 80
to 40 year old men, always.
I remember one time I
was playing against a guy
who looked Ross Kemp.
A skinhead, terrifying dude.
He's like this over the table.
- Like a brick shit out.
Every, every bouncer
you see at a nightclub.
- And I'm 15, 16, like this with my Coke.
And he had a pint and was smoking,
I'm there with my Coke,
occasionally checking my phone.
I don't know if that pissed him off
but in between moves, I wouldn't
look at what he was doing.
I would just check my phone.
And I would like...
Cause I'm normally thinking in my move.
So I don't really pay much
attention about doing it.
And I remember when I beat him
and he looked really fucking
angry and I was so scared.
I was, "Is he gonna hit me?"
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
He was like this on the table.
Like this.
I can't believe you won.
- I can't believe you've done this man.
- I can't believe you've done this.
People didn't losing to a 15
year old, that happened a lot.
- I can understand, I get it.
- But you know.
- I'm just really committed
to making this a manga mnow.
- Honestly.
- Yeah, please, cause from
a narrative perspective,
there's so many interesting ways
you could tackle chess just as a content.
- I wanna take that concept
of your friend being beaten
in the preliminary and
then just cut to the scene
where you're in the final.
And your friend is that
one guy who narrates
all you'll moves.
(all laugh)
- It's a speed wagon.
(indistinct chatter)
- He's like, he just did a [indistinct].
He's like, what's an [indistinct]
is and then he just goes
along with the explanation.
- Okay, this is gonna sound so nerdy.
There's one move in chess
that I always wanted to use.
And I don't know the name of it,
but it was the one where if someone moves
their pawn to and then in front of...
If you move your Pawn 2,
and then move it 2 as well
that you can then take it.
- That's an [indistinct].
- I always wanted to do that.
- Dude using a castling
is Op, you always castle.
That's all I remember.
It says, "Why did the castle there?"
It's like, I'll tell you why he's-
- Yeah, I don't know.
I remember they tried to teach us.
They were like, "Why don't you use
the Indian Prince opening of 1970?"
Because when I would do an opening move,
I always did the same opening
move because I just liked it.
It was nice and symmetrical, I liked it.
And they would always say
why did you use, this person?
Yeah, like I said, the
Indian Prince move of 1764.
And I was like, "What the fuck is that?"
I just like how the Bishop goes to boop.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
- Bishop goes, boop.
It just feels nice, you know?
It just feels nice.
- It's hard to explain
it when you're a kid,
because you're just
thinking four moves head.
And you're like, if this goes
here, and this goes here,
and this goes here, then you go there.
You know what I mean?
It's just how you see it, it was weird.
It's like any sport I imagine
where kids are really good at it.
And the adults are really pushy
and kind of almost borderline...
Some of the kids I'd say they had
a predatory relationship with it.
Because a lot of them, again, I said
they were very rich
parents whose kids went
to very good private schools
and they were destined to
go to Cambridge or Oxford,
no matter what.
And they would, you know
exactly what I mean,
what kind of kids I'm talking about.
Because the moment you spoke to them?
You're like, we're from a different world.
It's really odd.
- Chess is like their
entire world to them.
It was something that
was forced upon them.
Cause it was, you know,
it's something that
looks good on the resume
when you apply for Cambridge.
I mean, to be fair it
got me a few good jobs
where it helped a lot.
I remember some job interviews
where they liked playing chess,
and they would bring it up
and it was like, "Oh,
that's cute, you're good."
It was like, I don't know.
- That's cute.
- I think that's a really
interesting story that you have.
- Yeah, bottom line is we need
to turn this into an anime.
- Yeah.
- Most definitely.
- If someone was I want
to make a chess anime.
I would absolutely-
- Yeah.
- Just talk to Connor.
He has a very interesting story.
- If anyone would like a
free story, it's right here.
- Because it's the perfect
chance to teach people
about how to play chess as well.
- I think it's a really good game,
and it's one of my
favorite things to sit down
and talk to someone about.
Just talk and then play chess.
- I think it's a really
good way to, I don't know,
just have fun.
- Exactly.
- And it's also fun beating people
who think they're good at chess.
That's pretty fun.
- Power trip.
- Because I'll meet people
who have just been studying chess.
I mean, it's getting really
big on Twitch right now.
And you'll meet people who
they're really getting into it
and then you just stomp them.
It's like, "Oh, well."
Okay, here's the thing,
here's the worst part
about chess professionally.
Is that you normally know
five or six moves in
if you've lost or not.
But you have to play it for
another two and a half hours
and all it is
- Crappy.
- That's the difference
between casual chess
and professional chess.
Is that casually, you
always think you could win,
if you outsmart them.
Professional chess, it's just
how do I drag this out enough,
so that maybe they'll make a mistake.
- Oh God it was awful.
- It sounds horrible.
- It was awful, I hated it.
Cause it just got to the
point where it's like
what's the fucking point in this.
It's like, being a troll online.
I'm literally just being awkward.
- Just prolonging the inevitable.
- Yeah, and it's like,
"I fucked up, I fucked up
30 minutes in and now I
gotta put up with this
for two and a half hours."
- It's learning a game of league
and then five minutes in your own side.
- Someones hinting.
- Yeah, someone's hinting,
the jungle is just AFK.
And you're like, "Can I just FF now.
Can we just FF.
This is a diamond game right now.
No one's going to make a mistake.
- Yeah, because I remember this,
I never got praised for winning games.
They would always be good job.
You know when they would praise me,
when I made it hell for the other person.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
I remember when I...
This poor girl, I dragged it
out and she made a mistake
to a stalemate.
This game went on for
3 hours and 20 minutes
or something ridiculous.
- Oh my God.
It was something fucking long.
And I remember I'd lost an hour in 100%,
and I just made it awkward.
I wasn't playing to win anymore.
I was playing to make it awkward for her.
And so I did things that
you wouldn't normally do
to try and win.
You would just do it to block
everything that she did.
- To annoy them right?
- And I remember she
was getting so stressed
and I remember being like,
"This is kind of fun,
but also I hate this.
- This is torture.
- When I got back, it was coming back
into the football locker room.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
Nice one let's hit the shower son.
You really made it hell
for that 13 year old girl.
Congratulations Connor.
I was just like, "Man,
that didn't feel good."
I got a stalemate.
I worked three hours for a stalemate.
Are you kidding me?
- Absolutely cock tease.
- There's these other
worst ones there where...
I remember those people
who would constantly...
Cause you can ask for a draw.
You're like, do you want to draw?
And it would fuck my psychology up.
Because I was like, "Does
this mean I'm winning?
Does this mean his losing?"
And one time I remember
I regret it to this day.
I should have took the draw and I lost it.
He gave me an out.
- That's a learning experience man,
that's the character development we need.
- Yeah, I know.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I got a little trophy.
If you won three games professionally,
you gotta a thing called a Wendy.
I don't know what it was,
it was like a little-
- Why is it called a Wendy?
- I don't know, it's just
says Wendy on the plaque.
- It's just a Wendy's burger.
- It was just a Plaque
that just says a Wendy.
And I'm sure there's some chess people
who know what this is,
but I have no idea what-
- Please, educate us.
- I was so confused.
I was like, "Why does it not say my name?
I won these things."
- I'm not Wendy, I'm Connor.
- But I think also if you Google my name
I think my chest records come up-
- Really?
- Oh wow.
- If you dig deep enough.
People are gonna find them now.
You'll see exactly
which county and country
I was playing for.
- Don't stalk him though.
- Is there anything else
you guys wanna talk about?
- That was a huge detour, I'm sorry.
- I don't think we can
top that chess story.
That was an intense
- We just watched the
entire anime, in like-
- It's a story I love telling,
but it's one of those
things where it's like,
I can't bring it up if they're
not gonna be invested in it.
Cause it's such a long story.
- But it's a really interesting story.
I remember this last time you told me,
I was like, "We need to
talk about this publicly."
You've never talked.
- I bring it up occasionally.
- Imagine just being like,
"Yeah, I was a chess pro by accident."
And I was like,
"What do you mean you were
a chess player by accident."
(indistinct chatter)
- Easy conversation starter.
- From a young age though.
I was just always really, really good
at video games as well.
It always just clicked.
I'd always just caught them.
To this day I normally get
video games super quickly.
- You just have that talent man.
- You're a tensai.
(indistinct chatter)
- For me it was English.
If they gamed English I'd have
been fucking pro at English.
If they'd have made it a
spelling fucking simulator.
- I think that's a good place to end it.
- Thank you guys for watching.
We love the memes on the subreddit.
Keep it up.
- Hey, shout out to the patrons.
As always, if you'd like your
name on the screen right now
as you can see, or you'd
just like to support the show
then make sure to go over to our Patreon
because it helps us out a lot.
- Yes, and we also have
a subreddit, r/trashtaste
and also our Twitter.
- Titter.
Our Twitter.
I think at just @TrashTastePod as well.
- @TrashTastePod, yes.
- @TrashTastePod.
- So make sure to follow us there.
- Keep giving us the memes,
because the memes are fucking amazing.
- We love the memes
- The fucking smash pros
memes, was so fucking funny.
- You guys are very
creative with your memes,
and I appreciate that.
- [Joey] I'm loving the memes.
- If I don't comment on all of them,
doesn't mean I don't appreciate that.
- Yeah, we go through the subreddit.
- We see all of them.
- Just for the record.
- Well, I mean, this was
a diverse episode of-
- Okay, another thing,
so this episode wasn't scripted at all.
And none of our episodes are scripted,
but sometimes we come in
with a subject matter in mind
or a theme.
But this one, we were just like
"What if we just sit down-
- Let's just talk.
- Let's just sit down and start talking.
And we're not going to worry
about what we're going to talk about.
We'll just talk about whatever.
So if you enjoyed that, give us a comment.
Because this is I think
our very first one,
that we just had nothing. planned
- We had nothing planned.
- We could have just sat here
in silence and just been like,
"So what'd you guys want to talk about."
- I guess what kind of
balance do you guys want of...
Because I mean we can do either.
We're comfortable with doing either.
I think we're really interested to see
which one strikes best with you.
Do you guys like it when we
just throw out anime names
talk about shit then move on.
Or do you the overall topics basically?
- Make sure to smash that
mutherfuckin' like button
as always and subscribe
- Share the video and go and
subscribe to our channels.
- Ring the fucking bell.
(bell rings)
- Well this has been a Trash
Taste and I'm with the boys.
We'll see you next time.
- Bye.
(Garnt clapping)
- I gotta pee real bad.
(upbeat music)